we got an interesting development in the
case of kyle rittenhouse it may not seem
like that big of a deal but i think it
strikes the heart of
the conservative argument against colin
kyle no no hear me out
kyra now has a gun charge people were
arguing that he was too young to have a
weapon
and now the legal team has filed a
motion to have those charges dismissed
and it may be the case that the charge
is bunk anyway
if that one is is out then there's
literally no argument against
kharnas in any way clearly it was
self-defense some many people on the
left have even said well i shouldn't say
many people but some people on the left
have actually admitted
that it was self-defense or at least
begrudgingly said it was some kind of
conflict
although the left is adamant about
locking this guy up in my opinion if
this gun charge goes out
i'm not a lawyer we'll talk to one but
it seems like the only way he'd actually
get convicted at this point
is if it's political which very well may
be the case but
i've heard arguments from conservatives
the gun charge was the one that made
sense
now it may actually be uh it may be out
we'll see how politics plays in the role
plays a role in this but joining us
today is former lawyer for cow written
house john pierce and you're also
the founder of the nclu that's right the
national constitutional law union the
nclu and that's nclu.com and the best
way to think of it is essentially
the aclu for the rest of us or what the
aclu used to say that it does
yeah and that's sad uh yeah no it is
it's uh
it's kind of it's tragic and it's
there's a vacuum and that's why i
stepped into it because you know the
only way
that we protect our constitution in the
long run um and get out of this uh sort
of tyrannical
downward spiral that we're in is to
fight very hard
for people whose constitutional rights
are violated and make no mistake
even though you know i'm a conservative
this is not a conservative
organization it is not a republican
organization it's what it's what the
aclu used to say that they did
right which was to protect everyone's
constitutional rights and that's what
that's what we plan to do right on uh
and we also have a lot to talk about in
terms of january 6 as well
yes sir so i i believe that i represent
uh by far most of the
more january 6 defendants than any other
lawyer in the country i believe the
count right now is at 13
um and growing uh there's a lot of folks
that uh need help and uh
a lot to talk about on that case we
gotta go through all that stuff that's
important stuff right
absolutely we got ian jillian jeez yeah
hey ian crossland man what's up
how are you doing here uh thanks for
coming ma'am absolutely and i do i do
have to say congratulations to everyone
on the cassandra fairbanks acquisition
uh christina i i consider cassandra
essentially the best journalist uh
in the country right now amazing person
and she just does
such great work so it's amazing to see
you all team up yeah she's like
literally well not literally a rock star
but
very close in my mind she's there yeah
i'll say this of cassandra
on twitter she certainly is feisty but
her her reporting is
is top notch it's straightforward it is
i would say it's usually very
straightforward and well researched and
well
well sourced everything i see cassandra
wright you know to me looks
uh spot on uh she is feisty on twitter
you kind of have to be
feisty on twitter when you get hit
you're gonna have to hit back 10 times
harder or else
you're going to get eaten up so i kind
of like it right on
oh yeah i'm in the corner as well as you
have come to expect me to be
i'm very delighted because we have an
air conditioner now and that means none
of us are going to be shiny and sweating
anymore yeah the fans are gone
quiet oh man we got a special ac unit
installed because um
we we foolishly put the studio in the
highest point of the house
the ac is working for sure yeah oh it's
nice amazing and it's
it's one of these ultra quiet units but
we're moving into a new studio probably
in the next month or so
it's going to be way better yeah the
this the table is going to be attached
to the screen
it still looks like you have a little
bit of work to do but it does look like
it hasn't they just started today
so but yeah the table is going to attach
to the ceiling how about that i think
it's very cool
yeah and if it falls it makes for a
great episode they won't be able to fall
be part of the ceiling
i guess ceilings typically don't fall so
that's right yeah there's a secret room
in there is that right
no what are you talking about were you
messing with me what are you talking
about and there's no secret room
yeah that wouldn't that wouldn't be a
secret if that was the case i know
nothing about anything i think we should
rip the wall out and have it be
double the size ian's talking about a
small crawl space where the cat used to
break into yeah
i think tim lied to me earlier today no
what oh i thought you were i thought you
were
messing with me earlier no there's like
a crawl space with where the
ac unit is the cat used to break into
yeah yeah she used to come up all right
all right anyway
all right hey before we get started
check this out we got a sponsor we got
virtual shield over at
surfinginternetsafe.com
go there and you can get a vpn a virtual
private network service for fifty
percent off for life
it's amazing because when you go there
through my link brought to you by
timcats it says you get that special
discount now a vpn
helps keep your private data safe if you
browse on the web
i don't know maybe many of you have used
like the brave browser it'll show you
all of the people trying to track you
and steal your information
and those are the people who are asking
for it well not only will a vpn protect
you from that
it'll protect you from a good a good
amount of the people who are trying to
surreptitiously steal your data be it
hackers
creepy corporations big tech or even
nefarious government actors
of course it's not perfect but it is
that basic layer of defense here's the
way i explain it
we don't expect anybody to break into
our house you still lock your doors and
windows right
right so go to surfinginternetsafe.com
you can get 50
off for life it's only 2.50 per month
and if you if you go there now they
could they say you can actually get
24 months of online security from the
world's easiest and fastest vpn
for 59.88 it's actually 77
off when you buy when you buy uh two
years up plus you get 50
off all add-ons and other great
discounts on their other plans
so again surfing internetsafe.com i love
you guys virtual shield they've been a
sponsor of mine
going back to my very early days on
youtube years and years ago they've
sponsored me like
every step of the way so that is one of
the companies that have allowed us to
grow to this point so you guys rock
don't forget though
we are growing go to timcast.com become
a member
and you can help support the very
important journalism that we do here
like this one
where it says young turks mocked as the
shills for the establishment they are
if you're not a fan of the young turks
you'll probably appreciate that segment
but uh
we're usually not that bombastic but as
as john
noted we have cassandra fairbanks who's
writing articles we just hired a ton of
people
we have a bunch more writers we're gonna
have a a paranormal mysteries kind of
unexplained
show coming up with a new editor coming
on to produce that show and as a member
you'll get access to that as well
but don't forget you can also like this
video right now
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's jump into this
first
story from newsweek kyle rittenhouse's
lawyer asked
judge to dismiss charge he was too young
to have a gun
right now his attorney filed a motion
asking the judge to dismiss the charge
that he was too young to
possess a gun under wisconsin's law
arguing that rittenhouse's assault style
rifle doesn't fall under the definition
of the prohibited
short-barreled shotguns and rifles mark
richards
also filed several other arguments
including a dismissal of a video from
july 2020 that prosecutors filed motions
last week asking
a judge to allow his evidence
prosecutors said the video
shows rittenhouse hitting a teenage girl
in the back of kenosha's waterfront
but richards argue the altercation is
irrelevant to the case
richards has similarly argued that
prosec against prosecutors claiming
house has an affiliation with the proud
boys which is a
i love how they just say this is a
far-right extremist group yeah yeah
yeah whatever okay well we are we're
hanging out with john pierce now you are
not a lawyer
for uh written house anymore that is
correct
but you were telling me about this gun
charge is one of the reasons we want to
talk about it you said it was it was
total bs
nonsense but not just just to give some
people context to might not be familiar
they're charging him with what with
murder right uh there are multiple
homicide
charges i mean it's been a while since
i've looked at the you know the actual
charges but yes
for those that for whatever reason don't
know what happened there were there were
there was ongoing rioting in kenosha
wisconsin
kyle rittenhouse was there he had a
rifle he was
chased by some men uh we've actually had
richie mcginnis
witness actually we've had richie and a
bunch of other people who are on the
ground and witnesses to what happened
richie laid out everything experienced
which is actually the journalist
who took off he took up his shirt right
trying to render aid to one of the guys
who got shot he watched it all
and the gist of the story was that
several of the riders had set a dumpster
on fire
were pushing it towards a gas station
kyle or someone from his group put the
fire out
enraging many of the riders kyle was
chased
as he was running away he heard a
gunshot because a man standing in the
street fired a gun
actually initially people thought the
gun was fired up into the air but there
are some reports now there's actually
fired towards them either way kyle hears
the shot turns around
when this guy lunges for his gun kyle
fires in self-defense
the guy goes down kyle then runs to go
get help
he's chased by someone saying what
happened he says i'm going on video you
see this i'm going to get the police
someone yells something about get him
that's the guy he's then chased
knocked to the ground and some guy runs
up with a skateboard tries to grab
the gun and kyle fires upward and it
goes into his heart
that guy goes down he's dead we hit him
in the skull with the skateboard which
right then could
have killed kyle first of all so the guy
with the with the board actually yeah
right right here with the sharp edges of
skateboard he was he was
under full-scale assault the entire time
and the next guy who came up had a gun
absolutely he had a gun and tried
grabbing the gun from kyle and took
two two three to the bicep it was his
right bicep oh he's right by his head
vaporized he had he had a he had a glock
that he was about literally
a half a second from bringing down to
execute kyle while kyle was
sitting on the street kyle simply fired
that shot a half a second before he got
executed by wow by that person the guy
was holding the gun
and you know the guy actually said uh i
want to be careful here because of the
litigation around this but my
understanding
i could be wrong he actually said that
he should have shot him like later in an
activist rally said something that
effect
i i i think i mean i think it was at a
at his hospital room when he was talking
to one of his friends he said something
the effect that his only regret was that
he didn't uh shoot him and empty his
entire magazine
in tokyo that right there kyle was
uh he was a local resident people say he
crossed state lines yeah what he lived
what 20 miles away
it's a suburb he literally lived right
right across there
yes he worked in the kenosha area yeah
he worked in kenosha and he was and he
was there the night before he didn't
he not crossed state lines with any
weapon that's right right so what ends
up happening now is
you have the left saying he killed these
activists he was hunting them down he's
a white supremacist it's absurd
absurd and anybody who goes through the
evidence knows that's not true but there
were many conservatives saying
but he wasn't supposed to have a gun
he's underage
now we're hearing that they want to get
that the current lawyers want to get
that dismissed and you're saying it was
bs anyway so let's break that down what
do you mean by that
that charge is absolute nonsense uh mark
richards is a terrific lawyer um i'm
proud to say that i'm the one that got
him uh
you know kind of retain on that case
he's doing a great job he will do a
great job
wisconsin is an open carry state um the
type of uh ar-15 that kyle had that
night which is a long barrel ar-15
uh is completely legal in that state uh
it's legal for kyle to have had
possession of it
um at that age um the the the
if the that rifle had been
shorter potentially there may have been
an argument under that statute that
there's
an issue also if i recall correctly uh
you know there's
there's a very strong argument i think
mark made it in this motion that you
know that statute relates to various
sort of hunting you know
regulations that have nothing to do with
that case uh that that charge
should be dismissed it never should have
been brought none of these charges
should have been brought but that that
charge that chart should go away mark
richards is absolutely correct that that
chart should be dismissed
it was interesting seeing uh even a lot
of conservatives on twitter mentioning
that
maybe you know some people said he
shouldn't have had the gun
and they're going to get him because if
in the process of committing one crime
someone dies you get charged for that
and then people said you're allowed even
if you're not allowed to have the gun
picking up a gun in self-defense or
having one in self-defense is exempt
there's a lot of arguments about it but
i guess none of it matters because the
law itself doesn't even apply to what
kyle was doing
that lot is not applied to that weapon
it does not apply in the context of what
happened
the charge should not have been brought
this this is a totally totally
political persecution it's not even
close it's not even close
this this case uh needs to be dropped if
somehow someway
you know the these these political uh
you know soros funded prosecutors in
in kenosha wisconsin get some kind of
conviction against kyle rittenhouse
uh it will be a travesty and it will go
a long way
towards eviscerating the right of
self-defense for that all of us have
i i agree now i've said in the past
though i mean so this looks like
any any rational argument that a
reasonable person might presume
is is out the window most we had a
leftist on
who said he actually uh this guy destiny
he got
suspect he got kicked out of the twitch
partner program for saying
that it was the clearest case of
self-defense he had ever seen
and this is a leftist who said this i
mean this is a guy we had in here
and he was defending critical race
theory and social justice and all that
stuff we clearly disagreed but he was
like oh come on we've all if you're
being honest you saw the video you know
it was selfish
it's it's it's in fact virtually a
perfect case of self-defense because
on every on every element of a of of
self-defense
it's not it's not just that that he
meets the standard i mean he exceeds it
by
orders of magnitude like he was running
away like he was running away
like people were trying to kill him at
every moment like they were trying to
take his rifle and you know
shoot him with it like they uh like the
like the individual you mentioned
literally had a glock in his hand that
he was bringing down
who later expressed it was his later
desire to just unload into the guy
and someone fired first it's
mind-blowing absolutely
from behind him uh in in his direction
they attempted to ambush him
and and and when kyle turned around uh
joseph rosenbaum
uh was coming at him at full speed and
was literally right on top of him
lunging for the for the barrel of the
weapon as as richie has noted
is crazy that it's kind of how how did
this how did it end up that he got he's
being charged with these things
i mean look this is look this is why uh
the george sources of the world are very
very dangerous i mean
prosecutors local and federal have
extraordinary
discretion uh you know george soros for
all of his flaws is no idiot
uh and he has gone a long way in places
like philadelphia
and in los angeles with this gas cone
guy out there
is it chester bowden i believe that's
right i mean
they're fox yeah it's it's it's a very
very
dangerous i mean physically dangerous
thing for the citizens
of these cities because these because
they are essentially choosing
outright and announcing that they're not
going to be prosecuting
all manner of crimes i mean for example
in san francisco and you know california
essentially they've said
they will not prosecute uh shoplifting
crimes if it's a value of under like
nine hundred dollars i mean so
did you see do you see the neiman marcus
video i did not it's just like 10 people
running
out of the building full speed carrying
stacks of stuff well that's not
it's not even worth it maybe you can
call it a conspiracy
but no one's enforcing it there's
another video that just that just
started going viral
where it's people walking and filling up
bags casually with no masks on just
filling them up and then just walking
out the door
it's not rocket science to anticipate
the the impact that these sorts of
policies and these sorts of prosecutors
will have
on the complete breakdown of law and
order in these cities um and it's
happening
and uh you know regular americans see
that it's happening
and and the left uh may think may
underestimate regular americans
but i i i believe they're gonna get
punished severely um at the ballot box
as a result of this
now after chauvin i said kyle's going to
get life that's what i said after after
i watched it happen to shove him because
you had a few a few very important
points there
that the defense tried getting the venue
changed because of the riots and the
judge said everybody in minnesota knows
who this guy is there's no venue
where he can go and that to me is
astounding because there's an admission
that there would be no fair trial in
which case case is dismissed free to go
because we don't lock people up unless
they get a fair trial unless we go
through due process
when that happened then you saw the the
jurors being led
into the courthouse with armed men to
protect them from the extremists that
have been attacking brooklyn heights i
think it was
our book and center brooklyn center yeah
uh
clearly these people were being
influenced and they even admitted it
after the fact
saying that they were scared you had
maxine waters
show up right in the middle of it you
know demanding that everything continued
to burn if there wasn't the quote
unquote right uh you know
verdict you had you know joe biden uh
who's advocating for the uh
quote-unquote correct or right
verdict and his excuse was that well
jury deliberations had started so
therefore they're sequestered so
you know that won't impact things i mean
this is these these are things that are
fundamental i mean the the the criminal
and civil jury system
in the united states uh is so
fundamental to our freedoms
it goes back you know to the magna carta
uh etc yeah
the jury is the le the along with you
know sheriffs at different times and
different circumstances the jury is the
last bastion of protection uh for people
who are you know
wrongfully charged um look i will say
i've i'm a jury trial lawyer
that's what i do um i have immense
faith injuries um that show of interest
was very concerning
um but kyle is totally innocent
and i have complete faith uh that that
jury is going to find it the right way
but you think
like there's going to be riots the jury
is going to be sitting there staring
saying who wants to be
the the martyr they're going to say not
me
i have complete faith that that jury is
going to come back with the right
verdict
i i i the case is so the case is so
clear i don't see and i don't see a
wisconsin an
american jury coming back with any other
result
you know the the big difference between
that and chauvin is with chauvin there
was big arguments
about the amount of force whether or not
chauvin should have
kept his knee on his back or neck or
whichever you you you perceived it as
that he should have rendered eight
immediately when when floyd stopped
moving
so there's arguments well yeah and look
of course with
look with chauvin you have the 800 pound
gorilla of the of the
of the nine minute video that is shown
over and over and over again right
that's an extremely uh tough video uh
it's tough video to watch and it's a
tough piece of evidence to overcome
kind of the converse uh i think you have
with kyle which is is probably the first
uh you know a criminal trial in history
where it's literally
as if uh you were watching the super
bowl and there were 100 different
angles of high definition video of
everything that was happening that you
can sync up
there is there is simply no way around
the conclusion that it was 100 perfect
self-defense
yeah but you could still get a jury that
just says i'm not falling on that sword
i have complete faith in merck
richardson all right all right
i i think it'll be particularly
interesting but uh let's let's let's
jump to this next
subject january 6 because you know we're
talking about george floyd
somebody tweeted something about
conservatives in the double standard
there was some conservative who said
something about you know
why don't we know who killed ashley
babbitt we should have this information
released immediately with george floyd
we got this big show trial on the press
and then someone said like how are
conservatives not understanding
you know the the differences between
george floyd and ashley babbitt they're
like it's a double standard that they
don't care about floyd but they only
care about her because they're racist
and i said ashley babbitt wasn't chewing
on a speed ball behind the wheel of a
car
and then actively resisting police i'm
like i'm not not saying that
you know george floyd deserved or any of
that should have happened but ashley
babbitt stood up and looked through a
window and took a bullet
to the neck right so that's so so look i
mean there are some uh
so first of all i pray for for ashley
babbitt's family and i pray for them uh
to obtain the justice um
uh that they that they deserve uh
there's all kinds of strange things
going on with everything related to
january 6 so specifically with request
with respect to what you just mentioned
uh you know was she shot in the stomach
was she shot in the shoulder was she
shot in the neck there there's basically
three different stories
uh that have come out uh you know from
from the medical examiner from from from
the media um
etc um you know the the uh
chief of the capitol police who
either resigned or was ousted a couple
days uh after the event
a few weeks after his his firing or his
resignation
wrote a eight page letter i think his
name is stephen sunderland wrote an
eight-page letter to nancy pelosi
essentially
you know writing about what happened
that day in sort of an act after action
review
um there is no mention whatsoever of the
ashley babbitt shooting
in that letter whatsoever i mean what
why is that
how's that possible i mean i mean um um
so uh uh yeah now as to the as to the
but i will say look the truth is is
going to come out about everything that
happened
on january 6. it is going to take some
time but the the the true
january 6 commission is going to be what
happens in those
article 3 federal courtrooms whenever we
try these cases
i i i represent 13 of these people and i
will tell you that i am
we we are taking every single one of
these cases to trial
uh we're going to expose exactly what
happened that day
how it happened who's behind it what
happened etc
with respect to the double standard you
know
obviously i need to be a little bit
circumspect about the way i talk about
the particular cases that i'm a lawyer
in
um and you know juries will decide uh
you know
with the outcome of those cases but what
a lot of americans are saying and i
think it's undeniable in itself evident
is that uh you know where are the
pre-dawn
raids to round up the hundreds and
hundreds of people
the antifa folks who burned down kenosha
and portland and minneapolis and los
angeles
and in effect held a federal courthouse
under siege in portland
for over for over a hundred days
including attempting
not very effectively but attempting to
burn it down well they broke in several
times
oh yeah they used they used some kind of
welding tool to cut through the locks
yeah and
and they tried to burn it down when
human beings were inside yep
okay so you know we we have pre-dawn
raids
with uh ar-15s where there are
three-year-olds
in the house you know with folks like um
you know
73 year old pastors who are vietnam
veterans with no criminal record
um where is the priority to to protect
like regular american cities um and i
think that
it's just self-evident and a lot of
americans see that there is a
there seems to be a dual standard of of
justice right now and
they say think about how dangerous they
think that is a a fundamental precept
of the american system the american idea
the american constitution
is that there is equal justice under the
law when the faith
in that idea uh starts to crumble and in
fact i would say starts to be
shattered as it is right now that's a
very very dangerous thing for a free
society in a constitutional public to
hold it
very long i watch rich people just walk
on on
law i mean when hillary clinton's email
scandal dropped she was a secretary of
state and was involved in getting sidney
blumenthal in libya like
some of the most criminal actions of
getting us into a war in libya
directly against obama's direct order
that she can't work with cindy
blumenthal she worked with them anyway
like well she destroyed public records
and got away with it
class classified including classified
equal protection under the law
i'm sorry it was i don't think about
yoga or whatever yeah they were talking
about yoga birthday parties and of
course you as you as you probably
as you probably noticed the journalist
who essentially broke the story of
loretta lynch meeting with um
bill on the tarmac um has you know been
suicided
um so that one's that well the
the the journalists who brought the
story this one this this one i
i don't think you know i people look too
much into this there was an anchor
he reported the story he he wrote on
that story for years
yeah he wrote a book about it i don't i
don't look too much into that
it would that doesn't it doesn't make
sense for me for me that would be a
conspiracy in any way i think sometimes
people
you know what i think we talked about
this on the show here's a guy who breaks
the story turns out to be one of the
biggest stories
he then rides on that for a year so
telling everybody oh i'm the guy
reported but he just got talked on tv
about it
he writes a book about it he then does a
book tour about it
two years go by dude's got nothing left
i i i think
i don't think there's like we're gonna
wait six years and then retaliate
against him no i think it's a guy who
almost touched the sky and then you know
with all due respect to his family and
sad story
but i just don't see it but look uh
obviously i have no firsthand knowledge
about it i i i just do know there is a
lengthy you know count
of of of uh deaths and suicides in the
in a clinton pattern i i
i i think that's all exaggerated yeah
i've looked through so much of this
this this like this idea of the clinton
stuff and there's like a bunch of memes
and i'm like there was one where it was
like an accountant at a firm that once
worked with the clintons i'm like come
on dude the firm's got 3
000 employees or whatever people really
stretch it
you know what you got to be careful of
is is the confirmation bias in that
this this guy reported a story like six
six years ago and then like what are we
supposed to assume that the clinton's
like
in six years time we'll get our revenge
and and expose ourselves to massive risk
for no reason
oh a bunch of these these stories that
come out about the clintons are like
strange circuitous connections that i
think are just silly but the
the email thing is not that's nothing's
legit crime it was a crime that she
committed that she wasn't charged for
and loretta lynch was basically
investigating that right she was in
charge she was
the attorney general or something at the
time and then bill clinton went and met
with her and had a conversation
off the record that people could see
happening and then the charges got
dropped is that what it was or the
investigation didn't go through didn't
go forward yeah that's right i mean
uh you know james comey held a very sort
of uh famous or infamous you know press
conference in which he went through sort
of you know 15 minutes
of talking about you know how uh sort of
reckless and negligent bad this was
about the emails and then uh sort of
surprisingly at the end sort of dropped
the bomb that
uh you know uh it didn't rise at a level
of her being prosecuted or whatever
uh but you know that that's not
something that that's not something that
fbi directors
do um you know they they they have they
have an investigation
they make a recommendation to the
department of justice um you know as to
the evidence and then
uh that proceeds um that was odd to say
the least oh yeah i mean
2016 was one heck of a weird year it's
like it's like it's like reality just
broke
a lot of people like to mention that the
cern large hadron
cern a large hadron collider went off
right and then you know we get these
this the whole universe is in disarray
but i want to mention something too
a lot of people don't understand i think
there's a lot of people who want to
believe
in a lot of conspiracies you'll see like
a meme photo and they'll list a bunch of
names and then draw lines and connect
them
okay i actually go through those names
and i look up the records of the
individual where they worked
and i've looked into a lot of those
memes and i'm like
it's just you could you could draw this
you could do it to almost any any person
in a high profile position there's this
new one going around where um
the san francisco gay men's choir they
recorded this video where they said
we're coming for your children
and it's a creepy video i think it's
it's really creepy and purposefully
antagonistic like to an extreme degree
where they started getting serious hate
they took the video down
but 4chan's coming out and digging up
their names from the choir
and then connecting them to the sex
offender list i also started i was like
okay let's see
like if some of these things are true
and they do these memes they show the
name they connect the line
and then i th these it's just it's it
it's not legitimate it's it's it's not
real
uh far be it for me to say that
fortune's got it wrong but they
certainly don't have enough evidence yet
yeah so you got to be careful about
these these meme things that go around
because i've tried to dig up stuff on
this
and it's just not there look i i look i
used to be you know one of these people
uh
that whenever you would watch you know
uh the oliver stone movie jfk i think
well that's interesting
you know but i mean you know like come
on you know
was it really anybody else besides lee
harvey as well right um i i i will j i
will just tell you
that in in light of the the the
litigations i have been involved in in
the past you know four to five years
uh with respect to representing george
papadopoulos um and carter page
you know rudy giuliani and tulsi and
kyle and and now january 6th
um um there's there's there's a lot
there's a lot of narratives that are
turn out to be just
completely and totally fake and they end
up being just
destroyed after a period of you know
three or four months whether it be you
know the
sort of the russia russia russia hoax
exactly um or you know
but those are conspiracy theories too
that's the thing you know yeah and so
unless you have the hard evidence that
you can put out and you can definitively
draw those lines
yeah you know i just say okay yeah
whatever yeah you know
i'm just in in light of the in light of
the the things that i am you know
learning as a lawyer probably most
involved in in the january six cases and
again you know will it juries decide uh
what happened there
um they're just they're just a lot
they're just with questions with respect
to to ashley babbitt we still don't know
the name of the of the people who fired
on her who shot her
well i mean some people think that they
know um and and
i've seen allegations but nothing's been
confirmed no that's right i mean i mean
there there's they have not officially
named um the you know the person the
person who fired that shot
um and you know why why is that i mean
where's the explanation for what i would
say
because as political imprisonment is a
type of thing so it's political
protection
and both yeah and the issue the issue is
look the issue
well the issue is if this was kind of
you know
look just i mean imagine i think i mean
if it was converse
uh in terms of the politics um oh
i don't think i don't i don't think that
um you know that guy would be like
strung up in dc exactly yeah that that
the name would not be
you know his house would be brought to
the ground his business
right oh yeah yeah they go after them
like crazy i mean
uh in in there was there was a report
from the new york times where they went
the portland riders where they're
marching around stopped at some guy's
house
and then started like yelling at him
from to come out they threatened to burn
down his home for simply waving an
american flag
so of course we know if there was a
bunch of you know
uh uh let's just call them pink hats
like that when they shut down the
the congressional building that one time
and they occupied or they're banging on
the doors of the supreme court let's get
the door open
if one of them took a hit yeah woof well
it's also it's also like a look at the
brett kavanaugh uh confirmation hearings
right banging on the doors they were
they were trying to shut down that
yeah you know they were trying to shut
down that and where's you know where
what
let me touch on the insurrection idea
okay because that that just from a legal
standpoint any factual standpoint i mean
that that that is nonsense uh
because it just well it is i mean hear
me out which is just that
that's an actual crime i mean
insurrection's a crime
yeah um and and you can be sure can you
be charged with insurrection
absolutely and none of them have been
charged with insurrection
zero oh okay so so so it's ridiculous
you know
so you can be sure that if if the
federal prosecutors felt like the
elements of the crime of insurrection
were met i'm confident out of 550 cases
and counting probably going up to close
to a thousand at some point
there would be some such charge for
those that are listening and not
watching because we did the podcast uh
john held up a zero yeah just none none
uh you know we saw the capitol police
they're expanding
nationally i said i've heard some other
rumors too
but uh just for now it's like they're
gonna have a couple offices i have a i
have a soft prediction in that
i think once they get all of the people
who are actually in the capital they're
going to go after material support
they're going to be like our mission
isn't over we've got to attract on these
extremists who are providing material
support for these individuals who engage
in insurrection blah blah blah
it doesn't seem right now like there is
much of an end in sight
um for a little while there um it felt
like and i'm not sure if if i
felt like i heard this from from you
know the doj or from a prosecutor in a
public hearing but
it kind of felt like they were preparing
to wind down with respect to uh
rounding folks up you know that they
might charge another 100 or so folks it
might be you know 500 50 600 that are
charged
it seems like they're almost
reinvigorated uh right now
with respect to to you know they need
this they absolutely need this
well nothing look the the i mean the
country's obviously
the country's not going you know very
well with respect to you know inflation
and
with respect to foreign policy with
respect to all kinds of things so you
know there's a narrative that um
we got we got an election year coming we
do republicans are predicted
by many to sweep i mean i think even 538
is already saying the republicans are
expected to take control of the house
i i mean i i would be i'm not an expert
then they'll impeach biden
no they won't we have republicans i'm
not an expert you know political
analyst um but i look i mean the regular
people
in the middle of this country see what's
going on
on ev on every front um they all want a
basic degree of law and order um they
all don't want to see their you know gas
prices go up to you know
ten dollars or whatever it might go up
to um you know they they all want to
feel like we do not live
in a authoritarian surveillance state
and so so i
i believe it's gonna be a huge um red
wave in 2020
do you think the republicans should
impeach joe biden was it margery taylor
greene she was like she introduced
a bill to impeach him already yeah you
know i think that's more than one yeah i
think
i think it'd be reckless to say to say
at this point i mean here's here's the
thing that's happening it's bad
in the last several years in this
country and this is what brought down
the roman republic for sure
is is the is the is the um weaponization
of criminal law to attack uh political
opponents
because what happens is that becomes a
vicious vicious
cycle that descends into violence and
retribution very quickly
because because the political pendulum
will swing naturally
what what what what's the inverse or
what's the if if republicans don't fight
back
then basically democrats just keep
wielding power unethically
look republicans have to fight back and
they you know metaphorically they have
to fight back and they have to fight
back you know
extremely hard on on every front um
but but but i in the look in politics is
a you know again metaphorically politics
is a street fight
um you know and and and they have to be
tough
um but you know i'm i'm i'm a lawyer you
know i'm a huge believer
in the rule of law i'm a huge believer
in our constitutional republic
um and in our constitution and um you
know i
i believe that uh you know the right
conservatives um have to do it in a in a
proper
way because you know if it just goes
back and forth
uh with everybody just tossing out the
constitution
and just using every possible weapon to
destroy
their political opponent i mean there
will be there will be no end to it joe
biden lied
about uh being involved in business
dealings with his son oh i know
oh i'm no i'm not just there's photos of
it i'm no fan i'm no fan of joe biden
whatsoever
there are photos of joe biden standing
with hunter biden's business partners
from mexico
there's the communications there's the
witnesses this is
well above and beyond oh actually we
can't enter this period where we're like
you know we have evidence that joe biden
lied and was engaging in
selling his name and power but we're not
going to impeach him because then we'd
look like the democrats for what they
did to trump unjustly
yeah no and make no mistake when i say
you know sitting here right now
for me to advocate impeachment might be
a little bit reckless what i'm saying is
you know i i haven't take
i haven't personally taken the time to
look you know to look at the you know
the hard drive and to look at the actual
evidence you know obviously
i've heard a lot about that and if and
if the things that you know
seem to be on the hard drive um
which they seem to be then yes impeach
impeachment would absolutely be uh
it's 100 matt taibi dug into the ukraine
stuff
the the there was there was a criminal
there were multiple i think at least a
dozen
criminal investigations into mykola
zlachevsky and barisma
and joe biden got him shut down tit for
tat you don't want if you want the money
you shut this down
they absolutely were going after biden's
interests we know because of
uh what was the name of the confidant
for the biden family guy who came out
i don't remember his name oh god but
googly no uh yeah
yeah matt what was his name
bobiano or or something like that
yeah this guy this confidant comes out
and said he seemed very he seemed
extremely credible
by the way yeah yeah but but outside of
that because obviously i can't remember
the guy's name i'll discount that bit of
evidence
but when i i was covering a lot of this
i was looking at international news
sources i was fact checking i was
looking at all of it
it is beyond a reasonable doubt
zlatchevsky flees the country
there's an investigations room biden
says we gotta get a new prosecutor
because that one's corrupt
and he wasn't going after the corruption
the new prosecutor comes in
barisma guy comes back to ukraine
investigation's over you're free to go
your money's been unlocked don't worry
papa biden came in and saved your butt
donald trump gets in
dude flees to monaco it's like it you
got to be a special kind of dumb
or liar so so so we look at what what
donald trump was accused of
please investigate this crime we must
impeach him they impeach him over it
now we actually see the photographs
because of the laptop where joe biden is
standing with his son's business
partners what did he say to us
i have never talked to my son about any
of this stuff it is beyond a reasonable
doubt
based on the investigations that i've
done and there's still so much more
evidence
from that laptop that has not been
released i think republicans should
first thing they should do is they could
get in and just impeach the guy and then
let it all lay out in in court
if if in the senate if i'm in congress
in 2022 i think
you know there would be a very favorable
ear um um coming you know from
from me on that front um uh so he's no
conservative
you know and he wrote he wrote it he did
he investigated this
and he said the claims that there were
no investigation of this are just
wrong like none of these people actually
did any leg work no it's obvious
what did twitter do with the laptops
well that's well that's where i was
going to kind of go
they're obviously lying yeah well they
look the idea the the
look it's the point where uh you know
it's it's i think it's
criminal you know conspiracy that the
big tech companies are are involved in
uh
likely with foreign um powers uh to
decide uh
to to just try to just cover these
things up i mean for for them
for me for for them to make the new york
post story
about the laptop just go completely dark
for uh you know whatever it was a couple
couple weeks or a couple yeah a month
before the election
i mean a couple weeks after yeah i mean
i mean like what is that other than
blatant interference with the
what if the election domestic uh that
they're colluding with domestic
powers would that also be criminal or is
that legal then because it's american
cia or whatever i got to tell you it's
not my it's not uh my field of expertise
with respect to the law or anything but
what it but what it
certainly it like it's it's got to it's
got to be in violation of some
uh federal criminal statute for uh you
know for
for a private uh entity uh to
intentionally try to cover uh
some of that stuff up what actually as i
speak out loud about it
i think one legal theory that has
started to come to the fore which i
think is probably a good one
is that it's actually a campaign finance
violation um
because and i think there have been
lawsuits filed about this because
because they are
you know and again i'm not a campaign
finance expert
but but certainly what it seems to be is
them providing a in
an in-kind contribution to the campaign
that is cert i
assure you uh was probably not reported
and it was you know
probably working i i think it's it would
be more criminal um suppression
is different from promotion you know if
if they're pro
promoting an ad about biden for free
then you can argue they're giving them
an in-kind donation
suppressing negative news that's
something else that is causing i mean
you've got some civil torts there i
suppose with
harming the new york post under false
pretenses and defaming the new york post
why the new york post should have sued
for defamation when they said it was
hacked materials and the post said
repeatedly it was not hacked
they asked absolutely absolutely should
have and obviously you know they still
can right
it's not been that long yeah what's the
statute of limitations
it's different it differs by
jurisdiction uh sometimes it's a year or
sometimes it's two years
certainly it's certainly at least a year
but you know like
like we talked about i mean people like
james o'keefe has started to you know
step up and start to sue you know these
these companies um uh you know it's it
look it's got to be those big
organizations that have resources to do
it because regular americans you know
can't do it all right so here's what we
need new york posts why aren't you
filing defamation against facebook and
twitter for claiming
that the materials you had were hacked
even though you
stated several times they were not
hacked materials they lied to the public
and they used it as a pretext to cause
harm to your business
you've got clear damages the amount of
views you lost
based on the size of the story and the
the percentage of suppression on the
story
if they said they're suppressing it file
file
some kind of suit against them go to
discovery i want to see their algorithms
i want to know what percentage you are
suppressed hey make that information
public
then we'll know how much money you lost
then we'll actually have a claim against
them
or the people will actually get to see
someone fighting back well the near
press hasn't done it i don't know why
the other thing is joe biden should be
impeached just just bring it on
republicans win in 2022
first day the first thing should happen
i should rubber stamp that impeachment
send it to the senate
hey i'm not going to stay in the way of
joe biden impeachment but you know
they're going to love it they're going
to be like oh no now kamala harris is
president
there's that too uh you know there's
also the uh sort of i wouldn't be
surprised that's what happens
well there's there's also you know the
25th amendment lurking in the background
there's obvious
there's obviously there's there's
obvious you know health issues that are
uh you know
in the background have you seen the
photo of lori lightfoot meeting with
biden
i'm not sure that i've she's got this
look on her face it's like
like oh no and people were people some
people were claiming like
that look when you like people when
people finally meet biden they realize
this guy is broken like it's worse than
we realized it and i think it's
it seems to have accelerated um even
since the even since the inauguration
i i mean you know he's he's over there
you know traveling in europe and i think
he was given a speech before the
british military and it's like literally
a sentence can't be put together um
and that and that's um he was able to
say true not a shock at a pressure
i mean that that's a hard word for me to
say yeah
what was the word again truan and nana
shabba de pressure
i had to try really hard to figure out
how to say that word
and then frankie listed kickstarter
true international something under
pressure
i don't know i'm gonna have true shower
pressure
i'd like to i like to hear it people
could probably rap pretty well no no but
uh uh he could give him an imma
yeah would you true another shot at a
pressure uh if he didn't say that
intentionally that's the point if the
if the news they would make it nine
miles right nine mile if the new york
post went at biden or sued twitter
rather
and then it came out that actually the
cia instructed us to do this so now
would they
have immunity god i mean there's there's
so many like
fundamental uh constitutional issues
that it raises
if the um if the if this national
security state was involved in that i i
don't even know
is it where to begin is it isn't it true
though that uh like
democrats in california were telling
twitter who to ban
uh well i i i have that story i i have
heard that story and i have to believe
it's
probably correct um you know uh uh
i you know again with some of these
things um i'm i'm
so busy with some of these cases that
you know i don't have time to do the
same kind of you know
research and really look at the uh raw
data um
you know that that might be useful uh
but but it would shock me if that
weren't
okay i i have to pull it up because we
talked about it before but basically
there were communications between
democrats saying like hey
look at this and they're like oh we'll
get rid of it but look i think there
there's no doubt that uh look all of
these things are
are are connected i mean i mean the
radical left has overtaken
you know essentially every major sort of
institution in the country from academia
to wall street to silicon valley to
you know now um federal law enforcement
federal federal law enforcement and
and and was it mark milley oh chiefs of
staff
don't get me started i mean i'd love to
get started that was that was
that was disgrace that was disgraceful
um you know i
as i mentioned to you before the show i
was i served in the first cavalry
division
in the mid 90s and i was airborne and
i'm extremely proud of that and
i and i love this country um um uh for
for a four-star
uh general to buy into this critical
race theory you know
garbage that is so toxic and so
poisonous and is tearing this country
apart
um it just it just it's sickening um
you know the the united states military
has one job and one job only that is to
close with and destroy
the enemies of the united states you
know the most worrying thing to me about
what mark milley said was that it shows
we have a four-star general who is inept
and incapable of critical thought
right so here's a guy who's supposed to
be thinking and analyzing the
battlefield
and instruct you know but that should
not but that should not surprise you in
the sense that
um any in a you know in a peacetime
military when i say peace time i mean
you know a peacetime military with
respect to great power conflict
um the the best and the brightest of the
office accord does not
rise to the level of general the best
and the brightest of the officer corps
you know serves their you know
four years honorably and um then you
know has the ability to go out and do
some
more creative interesting things in the
private sector i mean the people who
rise to the level of general in the
peacetime military you know as we
classically know from the civil war
are political they're they're they're
political they're they're powerpoint
they do powerpoint presentations for a
living essentially they do powerpoint
presentations for a living so what
happens if a war breaks out
we have major major major problems i
mean look
look historically um again go back to
the civil war i mean the union had
massive problems with terrible generals
in the beginning of the civil war and it
just
huge um and so you know um now with this
sort of uh
wokeness layered on top of it uh look
there will be another major power
conflict it will probably be sooner
rather than
later because of the weakness we now
portray
to the to the world um and we're gonna
have we're gonna have a problem
um because of because of the sort of the
wokeness in in the
in the in the pentagon and the attempt
to you know make it a
social experiment diversity engineering
you know training program or whatever
whatever they're doing um
it's it's bad yeah so uh i mean
if china i mean if china i mean if china
invades taiwan tomorrow and don't be
surprised if it's not too too
far away um let's hope they don't um but
if they do
i mean you know let's let's let's let's
throw a little bit of rome in there was
there like a war conflict with rome
during their collapse
there was right barbarians julius caesar
and you might know even more about this
john
was uh leading his troops up north and
he basically
conquered all of gaul he was returning
as like the hero of gaul and they were
going to try and get him on political
charges and put him in the way
that's right so so what happened so what
started happening in the roman republic
is that is that um so when you were in
rome as a leader uh you were you were
immune uh
to kind of law fair uh you were not
allowed to you know do this thing where
you're just bringing like lawsuits and
lawsuits and lawsuits everything
um um but if you but but once you're out
of
uh power you know then then they could
do that to you and they started to do
that
um and uh you know julius caesar being
seen
as the threat uh that he was um
and you know being outside of roman
territory and at that point being a
military leader not um
a tribune or anything like that he was
like he you know he had the classic
choice to make as to whether to cross
the rubicon with his army
um and and and he made that choice
because you know he was
he was facing you know he was facing
political and probably physical
extermination or he was going to win
he's going to win or he's going to lose
that was the thing about threatening to
impeach and use political
things to go after your political
opponents that eventually one of them is
going to snap
and that's what caesar did he crossed
the rubicon which is basically the the
was it a wall or something that's a
river i think it's more of a stream than
a river but it's very famous
it's like um it protects it borders rome
and it's symbolically you are not
allowed to bring military troops beyond
that
that's correct that violates romans so
but he did it he was like you know what
it's either either i don't and they
arrest me and they destroy me or i take
control of the city
no that's right and look that's it'll
get assert at a certain
at a certain point when uh you know
tyranny becomes extreme enough
um it creates the the the conditions
you know for certain things to happen
what if we're in the calm before the
storm
a lot of people thought that 2020 was
the time at which trump was facing all
these charges so would he cross the
rubicon
the left is trying to claim that he did
with january 6 but he clearly
did not but what if 2024 is when you
know because
maybe trump said look we're gonna run
again we'll run 2024 and we'll win we're
gonna win back the house
we're gonna run again we'll win but what
if what happens if something happens and
trump done win we have i think social
media you can't
take the capital that doesn't exist
anymore our government is decentralized
now so there's no
place to march troops into would have to
be like some organized digital
cyber uh you know you'd have to shut
down
all communications take over yeah be
crazy organized
thing i what do you think i think i see
one guy doing that right now
certainly 2024 is i mean you know we
used to say that 2016 was going to be
one of the most important elections ever
in 2020 was going to be one of the most
important elections ever
2024 is going to be extremely
uh extremely uh high stakes um
i i happen to believe that and i i i
like donald trump i'm a big big trump
fan i hope
that he runs again i think he has
unfinished business and i think he can
turn the country around
i personally believe he is going to win
by such a a massive margin in 2024
that you know we're not going to have um
issues and i pray that i i
at least for now we'll see it's very
very early on it is we're in one of the
worst years for political uh
shows so this is for everybody you can
understand um i tell people like
the year after the presidential election
it's just like your lowest traffic
lowest ad rate
it's brutal then you get the midterm
which everything improves then you get
the
the campaign the primary year for the
presidential in 2023
so then it's like everything picks back
up and boy our election year is great
for political content but we're in that
law so we have so much i think you're
going to have
i think you're going to have a really
good 2024. i don't think foreign well
for your show first
i'm i'm not entirely convinced i think
people need to understand that 2016 was
insane
how insane it was i was in san jose and
i watched this mob
outside the trump rally chased down some
six-year-old kid
attacking him i saw a guy who got
punched in the mouth
because someone said he was a trump
supporter but he was actually a bernie
supporter
i watched them shove an elderly couple
in their late 60s to the ground grabbed
their moga hats and set them on fire
cheering
i watched a guy walking out going yay
trump and a guy runs up with a bag and
whacks him and then with it i filmed
this video gets a million views in a day
that was i think 2015. yeah that's how
insane things were then we get 2020.
look at what happened with january 6 at
the very least a ride at the capitol
insane and i keep telling people i see
no reason for this to de-escalate
now you're getting the brunt of the of
the of the federal government going
after trump supporters do you think
people are sitting there just being like
well it sucks but i'm gonna calm down or
do you think they're being like
stop and leave me alone now i'll tell
you my the funniest
smear against me the splc posted this
tweet of mine
where i said something like i think
we've passed the point of no return
the bridge has been the nation has been
so divided we can never go back and
civil war seems inevitable
and i was quoting a story i was actually
quote tweeting somebody
and the story said that like far-right
groups wear t-shirts calling for a
second civil war
so basically i'm like the news reported
these far-right groups are driving
around demanding civil war and i'm like
feels like a civil war is gonna happen
and they criticize me for it
as if it was my idea listen it's gotten
so insane in this country
and right now we're in this lowly year
so it feels like
everything's maybe chilled a little bit
but look what they're doing with the 1-6
commission look what they're doing with
setting up capital police offices
when we get in the midterms and the
republicans are looking like they're
going to win
the democrats are going to start ripping
their hair out and banging their faces
on the wall
screaming atop their lungs 2023 when
trump gets back up on stage and says
ladies and gentlemen i am running for
president one more time and everyone
goes
and screams cheering and they're
throwing drinks in the air whatever
the democrats will start pulling their
hair out again
it is going to be worse than we saw in
2016. it is going to be worse than we
saw in 2020.
i'm not entirely i'm saying these things
to be pessimistic i'm saying there's
going to be a conflict
understand why maybe it will be like the
scale of conflict we don't know
but come on i i love this i i've talked
about the potential for civil war
there's been a bunch of studies some
national security experts there was a
story i think in the atlantic said that
they estimated between 35 and like 95
percent chance of a civil war in the
united states and i thought that was
insane
it's like one to 99 chance no no it's
because
because there was uh like 16 people
interviewed there was a wide range of
what they thought but the average was
something like 65 to 70 percent
so then i i have people say to me
they're like so tim
remember last year when you were saying
that that we're headed towards a civil
war yeah what happened with that and i'm
like
a bunch of people ride it at the capitol
and they go
oh i'm like did you think that things
calmed down since then
so a few years ago when i was like man
if this stuff keeps happening it's going
to get worse
now we've got the one sick stuff going
on they're going after all these people
do you think that when they go after
that little old granny where they the
cop holds the door open for her
and threatens her or how about when the
feds went to that alaska woman's house
and kicked her door or whatever wrong
person do you think regular people are
sitting back
like this is fine or do you think people
are being antagonized to the point where
their brains are going to explode
you made me think of that meme with a
dog sitting in the house on fire going
this is fine
yeah i i i totally agree uh that the
level of intensity is being
ratcheted up uh you know to you know to
a very dangerous extent and i agree that
it will continue
uh to do so in in the current course
that we're on
um until uh 2024. so so i i
totally agree with you that we're gonna
see uh you know
we're gonna we're gonna see we're gonna
see the same kind of and probably more
conflict during the election uh than we
did in 2016 and 2020.
i i just believe and i hope and i pray
that
you know trump wins by such a margin um
that you know it kind of
puts everything uh you know a 49 state
landslide
hey i i really i really think it could
be i really think it could be big i i
think that you know like you said like
i think you just said i mean regular i
think the left
terribly underestimates regular
americans and i think when they think
that they have an advantage they press
it and they overreach
uh very much but i've heard a lot
there's been a lot of historical
comparison so
obviously we're talking about rome and
crossing the rubicon but i mean are
there really that many similarities or
is it just like a few things that people
like to to reference
right you you talked about you mean you
talk about
oh oh oh no oh look i i mean i i think
it's uh
i forget who it is i mean one of my my
second or third favorite podcaster after
you uh dan carlin has a podcast named uh
hardcore history
um and it's really you know amazing um
and and uh and he's you know big
series on raw big series on genghis khan
that he calls him that i love and
alexander the great i'm a huge um fan of
but he's fond of saying that you know
mean history doesn't necessarily repeat
but it rhymes
um and it rhymes because human nature
you know is eternal
um and you know there are trends and
forces that change uh
you know there there are individuals
that that that
rise to to uh significance who have
such uh a force of nature that they can
you know alter things
so you know um you you can't say hey
we're exactly in a situation that uh the
roman republic is in we're heading the
exact
same direction and outcome um but but
there are there are definite
definite uh similarities uh for sure
that we that we should that we should
draw lessons from you know and and try
and try to avoid
you know certainly a lot of people have
likened it to weimar germany
yeah some people have but some people
have likened it to
um the spanish civil war i i look i
think i think the 1930s uh
comparison to you know uh to the to the
threat of the third reich
is very apt in the following sense which
is um you know and people are talking
about this
some of them but i don't think enough
are but i think that i think that the
chinese communist party is is
is an existentially uh dangerous threat
to us
and to freedom in the world right now i
don't think we're paying enough
attention to it i don't think we've been
serious enough about it i think we need
to completely decouple
from china and we need to to isolate to
isolate them
uh and be building a sort of an alliance
of liberty uh that
steve bannon one of my other favorite
podcasters likes to say with you know
nations like japan and
um india and australia and we need to be
um
preparing for things with respect one of
the things about the german uh
how it reminds me of weimar germany is
the burning of the reichstag which
happened right after hitler got into
power i think was 1933
uh the the building the capital
parliament building burned down
and he blamed the communists that was a
false flag apparently no one's been able
to prove
and they've done the math and they're
like there's no way one guy could light
the whole building on fire
american conspiracy theory so theories
have arrived that he burned his own
reichstag down
and then used that as a reason to lock
down the entire country and start
stripping them of their
civil rights what was the the the
special security bill that was passed
because of that
the the um appeasement act is that what
it's no no the uh the
the an act that was passed in jeremy
the tip of my tongue you got it yeah
yeah yeah
it's on the tip of my tongue i don't
know the answer abling act yep enabling
the enabling act
that's what it was ah it's so close
enabling act oh the enabling act what is
that the nine name
yeah sounds good that was his excuse
he's like we need more power we need to
start arresting people and uh we're
watching similar things and it's now so
like you said it doesn't it doesn't
repeat it rhymes
a lot of people come out and they're
like oh nazi germany i'm like look it's
going to be different
but it's going to be similar in a lot of
ways what are we saying we have an
ideological faction
demands purity they are racial
identitarians they want law based on
race
and they are indoctrinating children a
lot of similarities there
and then one six you've got i don't even
like saying one six makes it sound like
911 but like this
this thing i don't know that it was a
false flag i've heard that there were
police officers involved with letting
people into the building that's a fact
that's a fact that
that is a fact so that is a fact i have
one i have one client named alan
hostetter uh
you know uh former police chief from
orange county and uh he might be
someone you want to have on the show
someday to talk all about this because
he's happy to talk all about it but you
know
he he is an individual um you know who
seems to have had uh
federal agents uh around him for a long
time um leading up
to january 6th um and so you know
there's they're just
they're serious questions there's
numerous videos where the police open
the door to allow people and in one
video a cop didn't say
they were they were they were urging
people sometimes they were letting
people in sometimes they were
urging cops are taking selfies with
people they're like hey
in one video cobb says don't agree with
it but i agree with your right to
protest
as people walk past them waving so it
could have been just mass
disorganization
or it could have been intentionally like
hey we can use this as an excuse to
impose
i think i think you all are missing the
bigger picture the police were in on it
each and every one of those capitol
police officers were like
we're gonna let all of our trump maga
friends in the building
so each and every one of these cops why
aren't they being investigated why
aren't they being injured
so i so i will tell you um we're gonna
put a lot of uh capitol police officers
uh on the witness stand when we try
these cases um why did you open the door
for these people
that's a pretty good cross-examination
question too yeah
it really is the jury hear that question
what's it gonna say
here's a video of you opening the door
and letting them in i want to do it
that's what i would have said i wanted
to avert a riot so i let them in
so they didn't smash me up okay is it
trespassing
not if i let them in haven't you seen
the episode of simpsons where
i think it's wiggum or someone tells
homer that if someone enters your
property you can kill him and he goes
hey flanders i think it doesn't work if
you invite him in he's like oh
right what if that does create a an
analytical
legal problem what if you are the
process what if you invite them in under
duress
what does that mean meaning that you
fear for your life so you let them pass
like someone you're like you're like
three levels into the movie inception
on that one yeah yeah there's something
like hey come over here and go in
i'm like uh these people are gonna break
me up if someone is in the front of your
building
and they have like weapons and they're
threatening you and so you're scared and
you open your door then i understand
in these videos quite literally it's a
bunch of old people doting about
waving little american flags and the
police just open the door
up stand aside and say don't agree with
it but agree with your right to protest
as people walk in
there's another video where the cop
literally just opens the door and one
cop poses for a selfie with people
like dude you're not going to tell me
that's duress now i think those cops got
in trouble right the selfie cops
i don't i don't know the answer to that
question yeah i i do know there's
another video that just came out
that that appear appears to show uh
folks sort of frantically changing into
um
you know different attire sort of other
trees um yeah
i've seen that i've seen that there's a
video where one of the first breeches in
the building they were all
in black clad you know black out gear to
obscure who they were and their
identities
and that's not a typical thing of uh uh
of trump supporters it certainly is not
uh
but but there were a bunch of a bunch of
trump supporters who said they were
going to dress like antifa
so the key the key thing is and again um
you know i have to discipline myself to
be
careful about talking about the merits
of these cases but i mean the important
thing is uh
where's where's the video where where's
the 14 where's the 14 000 or 15 000
hours of video now
to be fair um you know the the
department justice and the prosecutors
you know say and i i believe that they
are in the process of setting up sort of
a massive uh sort of database in the
cloud that will have
all that video that will allow defense
counsel um you know to
to to search through it um that uh
is still going to take a long time to
get set up and it's going to take a
massive amount of time to review
um all of that because we need to review
all of it
to understand um you know what what
happened that
that day um i also believe we should be
seeing
some video from before and after um that
day
i mean you know what why is it just
relevant um
you know what what which what the video
shows for january 6th
um january 5th and january 7th i think
it's important to point out there were
violent people lots of them
there's a lot of video there that's
that's ridiculous there are people from
the barricades out
storming up and and ramming police we
had richie mcginnis i think
this guy's everywhere was actually
squeezed in between
rioters shoving against these cops and
one cops like screaming as he's being
crushed so all that stuff definitely
happened
now the problem is the democrats on the
left
show that and they say look look look
look look
and i think it is part partially a
problem that many on the right are just
like
showing the cops opening doors let's
talk about all of it they were bad there
were people there engaged in very bad
activities right
but there are a lot of people who are
being charged when they were essentially
welcomed into the building
confused and understanding what was
going on uh that that is just
that is just accurate what you just said
um and you know very interestingly uh
and i'm i'm not a fan of fbi director
christopher wright i mean when
christopher wray was asked uh you know
questions by forget which republican
congressman it was
and asked um hey um constituents in my
district are wondering about these
people who were you know
ushered into the building and uh that
they're being um
charged you know how many people are
there like that and you know in classic
uh christopher ray fashion you know he
dodged and ducked and prevaricated and
simply would not
just simply would not go there and not
even remotely answer the question
because it's political
it's for power never let a good crisis
go to waste
that that is one of the tried and true
uh tactics of all time with respect to
taking over
no i don't i don't think the riot is on
par with like the burning of
you know the reichstag or whatever
nothing really got destroyed did it
they burned down the building didn't
they no no in uh on january 6. there
were some there were some actual
historical uh
artifacts that took some damage when
they when windows got broken in there
was like an old bookshelf or something
they burned the entire wreck shack i
don't think anyone died
yeah so so it doesn't it doesn't really
matter though because
there was something symbolically
destroyed uh it was the the normal
process by which they certified the
electoral votes
so that process is shocking to people it
wasn't a physical destruction it was
more of a
metaphysical you know oh that's the
process yeah
yeah and so it feels like an attack on
the on the on the uh structures of the
countries
you know abstract there there are
there's
actually an interesting legal issue on
that front which we've found you know
some emotions on
um in our cases which is that it is
actually unclear
um under the existing case law um as to
whether or not uh you know that process
that day the the certification of the
electoral votes actually qualifies
as um legally and technically an
official proceeding as that is
interpreted under the case law
because because those have to have a
sort of a quasi-judicial um
function to them that that it can be
argued um did not
exist that day now that that is
unsettled i mean the courts will decide
um
decide that um but look i but i but i
really believe and i've said
many times i think the institutions that
really
fell down in all of this so to speak are
the
state legislatures especially including
gop controlled state legislatures
because there's there's a the
constitution's designed
to avoid something like this and it's
it's very clear
if there are questions about if there
are any questions
the um the state legislatures you know
can and should uh
not on january 6th we're talking about
back in like you know december when the
electoral college meets in the states
they are allowed to very clearly under
the constitution
uh simply not uh send elect a slate of
electors uh
because they feel there are questions if
that occurs
and if either candidate if no candidate
gets 270 electoral votes
it goes to the house under the 12th
amendment where each state delegation
gets one vote and there is a process the
republicans don't like trump
the establishment probably certainly
don't like him right right right and
there's been there's been the insurgent
republicans the populist republicans
people who have joined the republican
party for the first time when i was at
uh i was covering one trump rally in
florida back in 20 i think it was 2016.
actually maybe it was 2015 i'm not sure
but uh there was a woman who said
i met a lot of people like this they had
never voted before they were totally
independent
they considered themselves actually to
be kind of liberal but didn't really pay
attention to politics
trump came along and he was saying the
things they wanted to hear and so for
the first time they were voting
a lot of people like that joined the
republican party yeah this started to
change things and the established
republicans who had a bunch of
a bunch of people who would vote are no
matter what for whatever reason just
because they were tribalists were upset
by it
trump is bombastic he's he rocks the
boat yeah he rocks the boat he's
demanding he commandeered the ship and
they were more than happy to get rid of
him
there's well there's no question about
that and i do think that i think i do
think those new
folks those populist you know folks are
ascended in in the republican party and
i'm one of them and
i hope that they are um but you know i i
know you're from chicago i'm from
western pennsylvania um and
you recall there was a rally in in
butler pennsylvania
during a massive massive one massive
okay so for 55
whatever the number was for 55 000
people
to show up yelling and screaming at the
top of their lungs for donald trump in
butler
pennsylvania okay western pennsylvania
is historically a
very you know old school kind of fdr
labor democrat
type of type of area you know con
socially conservative but but very
democrat
for that many people to show up that
ferociously frenetically enthusiastic
for donald trump
in butler pennsylvania speaks volumes
and i think that rally
uh in 2024 might be you know two or
three times that size you have have you
heard about those books the uh
about baron trump and the last president
you ever hear about this i have not i
see that he's really
baron's very tall like obviously that's
what that's what was in six seven years
i think he's six seven
that's the most recent thing is that
he's six seven yeah
yeah wow dude what what if like we're
we're just totally misunderstanding
what's going on
what's actually gonna happen is in 20
years baron trump who's this like six
foot ten
you know guy runs for president he's
like my dad was
president he's got this like deep voice
and he wins and then he rules the knight
no no there's a there's a book from the
1800s called about baron trump
and there's a the final book in the
series is called the last president
and it talks about how oh that's the
character's name is baron trump yes yep
yep
and the last president is a book about
uh where i think it's you know trump
wins the presidency on november 3rd
1893 or something and then the uh
socialists and anarchists from the lower
east side of manhattan
storm up to his fortress on fifth avenue
it's like the
weirdest thing i haven't read it that's
what we've heard
and a lot of people are like how how did
something like that happen
so the i'll call it a gag conspiracy
theory but there are people who
genuinely believe like time travelers
went back in time or something like that
something ridiculous
i was talking to will chamberlain it was
really funny because i was like there's
a conspiracy theory that people
travel invent time travel you know go
back in time to stop donald trump
and he goes that's what you do with time
travel
like of all the things you could stop
the killing fields
i mean world war ii yeah and then i was
like wait wait wait actually
yes if the democrats right now had time
travel
oh for sure that's what they would go
and do that would be their top choice
for sure
but but if i look as a gen x or if if it
does happen it's just got to be the
quantum leap uh
style time travel oh you remember that
show oh of course yeah it comes on every
day after stargate no it's got to be
quantum leap
but it's but it's at 7 pm so i don't get
to watch i don't like to see the intro
yeah i get every day i get to i get to
hear sam
sam go oh boy those are the days
those are the days simple simpler
simpler times
ziggy says you can't leap until you get
reelected president
uh why haven't i left yet well there's a
new movie have you seen the have you
seen the new uh chris pratt movie
tomorrow
yeah i don't like it all that much oh
you're a big fan i think i just love
chris brad so much that
he read uh i what i didn't like about it
was i felt like
it was poorly directed but i really
liked the concept and i really
liked the the attempt at doing a
different kind of different kind of
story structure
but there's just like it's the the beats
aren't hitting properly with
the humor and the action if it i just
have to confess if it has ryan reynolds
or chris pratt in it i'm i'm pretty much
sold
chris chris pratt deserves all the
support he's he's a good dude you know
he seems to be for sure stands up for
what he believes in to a certain extent
you know he wore the gadsden shirt and
uh
yeah supporting people who are pushing
back against wokeness and are successful
in hollywood that's that's a really
important thing
yeah it's a rare thing and uh you know
uh oh he's great magnificent seven two
are you making
seven fan oh yeah yeah yeah that's just
great magnificence yeah he does a good
job man we're gonna go see black widow
on saturday
if there could be time travel that's
what i would do is i would go back and
be part of the magnificent seven crew
with with the current with this with
this new camera i'll die oh well
uh no yeah not if you went back in time
no wait wait a bunch of them die
well several no not all of them die a
bunch of them yeah well there's seven
so i think like you know four of them
died the the the mexican guy
uh okay um ethan hawk and uh
and his yeah and his and his the asian
guys are the spoilers
by the way the bear guy does this
movie's like but
but the but i think i think that an
american guy does no i think the three
that survive
are the mexican guy who was he was
offended being called the texacan but
you know
the mexican guy uh and then oh yeah and
then uh
denzel uh survives and the american
and the native american red red harvest
yes yeah yeah that's a cool red harvest
is i mean amazing with the with the
moving shots with the yeah yeah and then
he also has the last of the mohican
scene with the tomahawk and the knife
um he's protecting that woman up on that
yeah yeah good movie it's a very good
movie
yeah see it's not all bad we're chilling
you know as much as the world might be
on fire we got good movies at least yeah
like um
i'll i'll see a movie poster i'll be
like oh that guy's in this movie i'm
excited and it's like i don't care what
the movie is that guy is in it i want to
watch that guy actually that's how it's
always
always been the power of the cult man
the power of culture like one human like
you were saying can rise up and alter
everything
i tell you he's one of those i mean as
long as we're on it i mean i tell you
that one of those guys that i see is one
of those guys
is um are you a fan of the hbo series
deadwood
no i've not seen it oh ian mcshane um
you know he always
he plays kind of the main sort of bad
guy but with some good traits in in
deadwood um
but i think you know he he can he can
tend to be one of those uh
one of those folks um powerstop you're
the movie um yeah he's great
yeah he's a good bad he's a good bad guy
yeah he's very good i didn't think he
would i didn't
i didn't i wasn't a huge fan of uh the
pirates of the caribbean
sequels i loved i loved the first one i
think the first pirates of the caribbean
was just an incredibly good
movie um i think the sequels were not
that good and he i think he was in one
of
those
sequels so that's the one caveat i'd
give but i haven't seen any of those
you haven't seen nothing out on movies i
i went to theater school
and they were all really anti-cinema it
was very weird yeah i was like i kind of
stopped watching yeah
it's because theater is a dead medium
yeah they were like i read plays i don't
watch
tv the other one that i uh i'm just my
favorite
tv show ever is um black sails on stars
um
you know that's kind of like game of
thrones combined with pirates of the
caribbean oh that's
that's a terrific terrific show yeah
when are they going to start
making a uh uh a series about january uh
six
yeah i i i'm half joking but i believe
there are multiple ones underway yeah
yeah right
yes wow there are multiple uh both
series and documentaries that are
underway yeah they just came out with
one i'm not sure what news
yeah organizations well i think that
they're i i i i mean i know that there
are a couple um
uh that hbo um is working on so i think
one showtime series on january 6th
oh my gosh so it must not be that big of
a deal then because like are there any
movies about covet yet
or is it two it's one of those two soon
i think there's
i think i think there's uh there's
pandemic i think it's called uh which is
kind of a documentary that i think
documentary they like they like doing
these like
uh it's hollywood so they're leftist
and they like doing movies that can push
politics through culture like when they
did
um what was that fox movie where they
went after roger ailes or whatever
oh uh bombshell yeah yeah oh bombshell
yes
well there was a couple yes i was
thinking of the hbo one where uh um
uh russell crowe plays uh roger ailes in
the hbo one i think i think uh but but
but i i like bombshell i thought
bombshell i thought no no no no right
right like right yeah uh the story about
what roger sales was doing sure he
sounds like
he sounds like a bad dude right but are
they gonna pick up a movie about
like i don't know antifa burning down
buildings yeah i mean they're not gonna
do that they'll wait till it's
politically expedient
right with virus movies yeah when the
when the left needs to regain control
from antifa
then they'll make you know us
when they start when they when their own
starts to get eaten which always happens
with that kind of
political philosophy but but you know
look with respect to buildings being
burned down and
you probably know more about this than i
do but i mean with respect to like
kenosha for example
i mean you know there there were there
were houses there were multi-level
houses
uh in which you know there were spray
painting on the houses you know please
don't burn this house down because
there's a disabled person like on the
top floor
yeah i mean this isn't this isn't
kenosha like on you know lake um
michigan i suppose and what do the cops
do the cops didn't do anything about it
they they the the local
and state government of wisconsin uh
completely and totally
abdicated its most basic fundamental you
know obligations to
actually provide law and order you know
it's obviously happened in other cities
as well with these
chop zones and you know chad zones or
whatever they're called no goes on
you know and that you know and that and
that's totally unconstitutional i mean
that that violates the guarantee of a
republican with a little r government um
yeah well they
uh the police took away your right to
defend yourself right and uh now that
you can't
the extremists and the criminals and the
rule breakers and the law breakers can
do what they want
then when their political allies take
the d.a the police don't even go after
the crimes of you know that are more
extreme so
so it's it sounds like it almost sounds
like a system
all right we're playing yeah if you were
saying earlier the
tracks were on is dangerous i think
you're right because
that we can't talk about certain things
on youtube not that youtube's the only
place to have kind of like we can talk
about it on timcast.com or whatever but
there's things that we we can't talk
about regarding the chaos
that is disturbing that we can't debate
dissect america no as
it's very unsettling as as americans to
have that sensation i i mean
you know i'm much older than anybody in
the room i think but but i mean you know
even look growing up and even i'm sure
when you were growing up i mean you just
the the sensation in america was that
you could like you know
really you know argue it out and hash it
out and like stay up all night in
college and like debate anything and
talk about anything
as long as you know as long as you're
you know civil to the other person
do you remember skokie illinois in the
aclu um i
i i know uh that there is something very
relevant with respect to skokie and the
aclu but i can't
um put my mind it was a bunch of
neo-nazis who were marching through a
jewish neighborhood and the aclu defense
defended them
and and that's exactly so that's a
that's a perfect example and thank you
for reminding me of why i started the
nclu because
because the the only the only way to put
to preserve the constitution is to fight
for the rights of those who you despise
the most when it comes to their
to their viewpoints um and you know
right now it happens to be uh
it seems you know it is conservatives
that that that are
uh you know needing protection right now
but tomorrow it's gonna be it's gonna be
liberals and
you see what china just did with banning
lgbt groups i did not see that wechat
one of their largest you know social
platforms banned a bunch of lgbt
accounts
so you can see what what power does
in the united states just so happens the
left communist faction
uh and the marxists have a lot of
institutional authority and
and and people to understand this that
it there is a massive infiltration of
marxism
in this government what they need to
understand about critical theory and
marxism is it's the idea of the
oppressed and the oppressor right
that is that the system is inherently uh
you know bad and evil it must be torn
down um right so so it's not it's not
about like stalin's sneaking into the
government
it's about quite literally there are
people in the government the military's
doing it
the the the uh what did we just have was
it lockheed where there were like
you know white people got to recognize
that yeah yeah yeah so
at a military-industrial complex our
government our police forces our army
are all embracing marxist theory they
might not know that but it literally is
marxist what's concerning is if it's a
presser
and a press and i'm the oppressed then i
overturn the oppressor then what does
that leave it leaves me to become the
oppressor
it doesn't it's not meaningless it's
just power structures
it is it is it's an ideology that is
basically like
um how can i describe it it's like when
you when you when you look at an atomic
structure
and you find the one frail atom that
when you flick
the whole thing crumbles sounds like
fluorine well it it starts
it's not floating well this was pretty
electrostatic or electro elastic
i mean this was known as hydrofluoric
acid i mean
what you're talking about is the same as
what used to be called critical legal
theory which became actually pretty
ascendant
you know at harvard law school yeah a
couple decades ago but it's but it's the
same it's the same
exact idea yeah yeah they they want to
find a way to demonize a villain
create an other it's very demagogic i
suppose
and it works so what is it but it's
really really quite smart because what
they'll do is they'll say
you're a racist and quite literally you
have like james lindsey being like
discriminating on the basis of race is
wrong and they go racist
it's like okay so yeah that's what it is
that's what they believe
if this theory is oppressor and
oppressed and the oppressor
the powerful are press oppressive by
nature is that part of this theory
no no no no so uh initially with marks
you have like the the the class
right the bourgeoisie the proletariat
the working class the elites the
political class et cetera
then you get critical race theory where
they're like white people
critical critical with white people
basically
right the race theory so now with
critical race theory you have oppressed
oppressors and the white people are the
oppressors and the people of color are
the oppressed
and is the theory that if you were to
remove white people from the equation
that there would no longer be an
oppressor
uh that white people need to recognize
their privilege and give up their power
this is very disturbing it's meaningless
because you can't take your skin color
off right
yeah so the idea ultimately is that you
will always be an oppressor no matter
what
all of which of course is precisely why
we have certain laws that just
just explicitly outlaw this kind of
thing um and it's and it's and it's
fascinating uh
it's fascinating to watch some of these
um you know state and local governments
and corporations
attempt to um you know implement laws
that are just
that are so flatly uh illegal and
contrary to like the civil rights
laws you know that were passed in the
1960s but you know and they think that
they can just
get away with it and they will unless
they're challenged critical race
theorists
hated civil rights one of the core
tenets of critical race theory is
critique of liberalism
they felt that the the the liberal
liberalism with a little ill
right yeah they thought that the
democrats and and desegregation and
civil rights was actually depowering
their community they hated it they were
very critical of the democrats
first of all you had the democrats that
were pro-segregation and then also the
democrats started to say okay well maybe
we'll we'll get behind these bills for a
variety of reasons
and there was there was a letter
circulated during the ferguson riots
among activists that argued segregation
was a plot by white democrats
to force black people to exist
underneath the the
economics of the white system this
desegregation yeah right so so
what uh what these activists were saying
when they were this letter
before the end of segregation when
everything was separated
they said black people had their own
wealth their own neighborhoods their own
communities
their own churches they had their own
wall street along comes the democrats
and say hey we should end segregation
it's wrong and as soon as that happened
you have these two systems where yes you
have a lot of very wealthy white people
but the black community was building up
their wealth
now they're forced to exist at a lower
economic standard to the white people
that what they were basically arguing
was when you had segregation
a black person would run their own
restaurant with the end of segregation
the black person would go work for the
white man's restaurant
now i think that's a bit silly you could
still have your own restaurant you can
still have your own communities
and i think it's an overtly racist
ideology and the end of segregation was
a very very good thing but these
activists genuinely believe
that we need that they believe
segregation was
uh some it's something they want i'll
put it that way when they hate martin
luther king
they but they but they know that he's
popular among liberals and the liberals
are the ones they can exploit
so they say things like yay dr king and
i always say this to my to my woke
friends
martin luther king jr he uh dr king he
said i have a dream
that one day my four little children
will be judged not by the color of their
skin but by the content of their
character
how are you fulfilling dr king's dream
exactly
and they say yeah you don't even know
what he was about
okay i guess i know he said those things
so do you think
that allowing schools to implement ra
race-based discrimination
is helping dr king's dream or hurting it
wow now hold on path is long let's find
out you're getting a lot of leftists who
have no problem criticizing him
because it's becoming so prominent and
prevalent that they're now
much more free to do so so when uh we we
talked about this book that's being
taught in school it's called not my idea
it's a children's book where a little
white girl is exposed to the truth by
her teachers about
race and she's angry with her mom who
lied to her and she screams i'm tired of
you lying to me mom tell me the truth
i see race and the mom says oh no
then there's a whiteness contract with a
white hand reaching out in a devil's
tale
yeah white white people are the devil
they say you've got to see this book
they're teaching this to children in
dozens of schools but
in many of these schools once they get
to that portion where it shows the white
person as the devil they stop
they don't show it and they say you can
read the rest of the book on your own
you know why
it's the insidious nature if they come
out right now
and tell children white people are the
devil their parents will flip
out but if they give them the beginning
of the book
see police brutality is wrong they were
lying to you these liberals might be
like huh okay
they have to do it slowly slowly it's
insidious these liberals are easy to
exploit because they look at something
and they say that's unfair
they've got to do it slowly once enough
liberals support this book then they'll
turn the last page and say white people
are the devil
and then these people go oh yeah
well i think these look these parents
look these parents these moms are
starting to stand up in these school
board meetings
which i think is a very good thing i
think when i was driving down here i
went through ludon
county right right loudon which which is
of course where uh you know they wanted
to shut down debate and they dragged out
uh the sheriff's deputies dragged out
the parents who wanted to actually
finish the period of debate um that was
called
for right um but you know look the the
the the way that these things are gonna
turn around is
is that people you know people who love
this country and you know
moms at a certain point will protect
their kids uh but these folks are gonna
start running for the school board and
they're gonna start running for local
offices and you know i mean good people
have to
good people have to get in politics and
run for um office because that's i mean
like that's where the real power is
that's where real change comes from is
where you can actually take your pin and
you can sign you know a piece of
legislation
and um you know i i think that's
starting to happen it certainly feels
like it's starting to happen
i'm starting to think that this 100-year
experiment of public school systems is
is showing its cracks as
flaws and the dangers of putting your
kids in a foreign
environment and letting just letting
letting things happen to them strangers
can tell your kids
so many bad teachers just as awesome
terrible
terrible old angry
evil worthless useless i'm going to say
the worst stuff
no they're probably fine people but just
not not able to handle
young a group of 30 kids at a time it
was terrible
yeah i mean it's just it's just i mean
they're they're states like you know i
suppose new york and california come to
mind where i mean
the public education you know the public
school system seems to be
it seems to be disastrous and and it's
hard to know what what to do i mean i
think the solution is probably
multifaceted i mean it involves some
degree of school choice it involves some
degree of
um you know getting the funds actually
where they need to be
to make sure that you can reduce class
sizes and you know get good teachers in
there but but yeah i mean
we we we can't we cannot have um a
system in this country
um where you know and i'm very fortunate
to my kids you know go to amazing um an
amazing
private school but you cannot have a
system where um you know a certain
number of elite kids you know
um have teachers who are kindergarten
teachers with phds and they have an
amazing experience and then you have
you know the the masses of people whose
kids are not only
in physical danger um but they're being
indoctrinated like this
voucher program yeah look i i'm a i'm a
i'm a huge believer in in uh you know
choice and competition
and so you know school choice and
voucher programs uh in competition
um you know generally speaking seem to
me to be very good ideas
very good ideas um i think you know the
healthcare system also needs you know
more competition
um and whatnot i think i think the trick
becomes exactly how to implement
these things um yeah you know so that so
it's actually effective uh but what but
but what we have right now in these
big blue states and these these these
these cities
is not it's just not tenable so
something else that's trash well it's
just i mean
the cities themselves man i'm just so
i'm i am anti-city right now
it's not a good time to be in a big city
we were outside in the front today
with uh andy um andy is a guy who's
gonna be he's gonna be running all the
wreck area stuff he's gonna be running
the grind bar and we're gonna be selling
events and stuff so he's we're standing
in the front and we're trying to plan
out like so where do we build the mega
ramp
like where do we put the giant launch
for the skate park
and it's not about look i understand not
everybody can you know go and buy
materials for a skate park
but you have space you can walk outside
with your friends and just look at the
grass and say what can we do here
what activity should we have in these
cities it's brutal man you live in a
cubicle
yeah your kids are in a crammed school
environment he doesn't even know their
name
teacher's like who is this you're in my
class um
miss wilson i've been in your class all
year huh i can't even tell i got too
many kids
you know who i don't live in that it's a
different it's awful different type of
versatility
no and i think that could look i think
that you're going to have uh
people start to look people who want to
live a certain way and believe in
certain things are going to start
self-selecting
out of the cities um and to be you know
uh
in places that seem safer and in which
you know they're not attacked for having
a
maga hat on um and you know i think that
uh you know and obviously
with uh with covet and the way folks
have gotten more used to working
remotely i think it's going to
accelerate that trend and that
and that and that could lead to further
you know that could lead to further
division in the country because you know
we're
i think we're going to have people sort
of segregating themselves away from
each other um because there's just too
much volatility right now
yeah you know we're going gonna go
tomorrow
see a movie hang out have some candy and
popcorn
then we're gonna just relax and enjoy a
saturday we've been filming it we make a
vlog out of it we're gonna start ramping
up doing daily vlogs and everything but
the point is
there's got to be something else to kind
of clear your mind oh yeah help you
focus on other things i do music because
i want to scream when i want to
when i want to exert my rage on someone
i just got to turn it into song i gotta
scream with my body's full vigor
and it's it's a bit of a vocal cord yeah
but it's good for my mind playing the
drums
it doesn't hurt other people because
like taking it out on someone else is
terrible you can't scream in a city
though they do it online and they're
text and it doesn't
yeah they can kind of tell when they're
reading on their in their text
but if you're if you live in a city like
so i it's hard i lived in the city i
lived in brooklyn
can't have drums can't play guitar you
can play guitar but it's like within
certain hours because like you hear the
pounding on the floor then and unless
you're
really good your neighbors are going to
complain yeah they're going to complain
no matter what they don't always
complain if you're really good
i lived i lived in an apartment where
someone in the building worked a
graveyard shift and they're always like
it's like 5 p.m and they're like excuse
me i i understand but look man i got to
sleep and we're like we'll do our best
because we're trying to be nice
it's brutal
you know listen to the stories about how
um alexander uh
the great's mom was you know like super
difficult sometimes and then after
after he died from partying too hard
there was like literally like 40 years
of
warfare among his generals to try to
sort things out which you know i think
which makes you feel like you know it
could be worse i heard that he was
poisoned
i heard that theory oh well for sure
that's a major uh
theory uh uh you know i don't i don't
think anybody
knows for sure i would be surprised if
he wasn't at this point
they had look he he had he had it he had
put together
the world you know the largest empire
that the world had seen at that
point um and so you know so there was a
lot of folks with a lot of
you know motivations um to do such thing
uh look
clearly he seemed to um uh you know like
to like to have a good time
as well um you know and so who knows for
sure um
with respect to you know the amount of
alcohol that you know he was uh
you know supposed to consume um but but
no like
i i would say that the i would say that
the consensus among serious historians
is that yes he was he was assassinated
he had
led all his generals across you know
persia and was conquering the world and
and they were like okay we did it well
no they yeah and we go
home yeah they got basically like
halfway like through india and they're
kind of looking around at like the
himalayan mountains in the snow and
they're like
okay like i mean we're like seriously
like what what what's
like what's the point here my assumption
was he was like we're gonna go forever
and they were like no we're gonna we
have to stop him
he's gone too far well he's one of the
most i mean he's one of those
fascinating personalities
in history and he had an insatiable he
had an insatiable appetite to conquer
everything he was he was
you know tutored from a young age by
what was it aristotle uh you know his
his mother his father was one of the
most powerful figures of his age that
handed him
like a ferrari of an army that was
tailor-made to take
to take over persia uh essentially and
his mother is one of the most um
you know sort of powerful fascinating
manipulative
uh you know female characters in in in
the ancient period
for sure um and so yeah the alexander
great story is a good one
well how about we ask the audience over
in the super chats if you haven't
already give us a little tap of that
like button subscribe to this channel
become a member over at timcast.com
and share the show if you really like it
all right the first and most important
question hutch the wolf says hey what
happened to the stream last night
well we have to be very careful because
youtube is communist so it's on rumble
so um uh it's on rumble and uh it's on
itunes and spotify
and all the podcast platforms but it
ain't on youtube and that's youtube's
fault so
uh i'll just put it that way all right
let's see what we got here
oh this is where you take questions from
yeah we just read the read the chats and
see what's up nice
mickey stone says a new dark matter
research facility is being built two
kilometers underground victoria
if they succeed australia will have an
infinite energy source
you know is that real they've been
looking for dark matter for like two
decades
and now that i'm studying quantized
inertia i'm i'm wondering if
maybe you know there's lots of ways to
look at something that exists so like
this ball of obsidian
you could write different theories
explaining the the existence of this
ball of obsidian from different layers
like one's the
the cellular theory of behavior one's
the atomic theory of behavior one's the
subatomic theory and they're all right
even though they all are different so i
wonder if dark matter could be explained
and there could be
theories that explain reality without it
so then you go to go to the university
so the one thing i contribute to like
the only thing i can contribute to that
uh
answer is that i think if australia
develops it there could be a lot worse
people that develop it so oh yeah you
know
all right trevor schoon says when
talking about crap
critical race applied principles you
said they consider whiteness property
do you all think they will try to put a
tax on whiteness do i think they've been
trying to they've come out and said it's
called reparations
oh yeah yeah so if you're if you're like
a
uh well then they've also they've also
started to you know just explicitly uh
provide more benefits to folks who are
not white whether it be
getting a covid vaccine first or it be
certain you know financial benefits so
yeah let's say you're a uh you're from
ukraine
you moved your parents moved to the
united states and then they brought you
with him as a child
or actually you know luke's a good
example luke is from poland his family
moved here with him when he was young he
grew up here
why is he paying taxes in reparations
for something had nothing to do with
because he's white so some people
receive and some people lose
yeah that's a tax based on race
all right let's see angry waffle 2 says
i live very close to kenosha
my family still lives there if kyle gets
an excessive punishment
we need to rise up or punishing
self-defense will be the norm
yep yep so people need to uh
i can't tell you what the most effective
thing to do but organizing you know
understanding protest
understanding your power in media
understanding your power and industry
you know this is the funny thing about
like january 6. these people think
and and i and i get these comments from
people where they're like we have to
fight it's the only way and i'm like oh
that'll give you control of like
institutions and colleges to
indoctrinate children
no it won't do anything you need to
actually be professional persuasive
resourceful
and get jobs and like you know people
can do so
people want to know how they can fight
back apply for a job at google
there you go become part yeah there
there has to be almost a counter march
through the institute
the counter long march through the
institutions um to to to try to you know
start to take
some of these things back yeah maximin
says tim facebook wiped all kyle
rittenhouse and kenosha shooting content
search facebook for his name or kenosha
shooting nothing comes up at all
they're in the process of removing
search terms related that's because well
two reasons one advertisers don't like
it it's
not good and there's probably a
political component where they're like
hey if liberals can't see it happening
they'll just
assume the narrative is true if people
watch that video they're going to be
like this guy's
demanding himself i mean it makes
logical sense because every single video
shows that he was defending himself and
remember there was there's there's like
thousands of videos showing it's not
just one
he was on the ground the guy was about
to smash his head with the skateboard
could have killed the guy yeah we did it
no he the guy the skateboard did smash
his skull with the skateboard
um and could have easily killed him just
with that blow but but the person that i
think you know you're talking about is
the person
with the glock who is literally coming
down to shoot him executing yeah he's
like walking up to him with the gun
he's got a glass well he think well he
tried to well he tried to he tried to
fake surrender yeah he tried to figure
it out he backs up he tried to fix it
and then kyle
what is the what is the precedent like
if you go into a mob where people are
fighting
with a gun and you walk into it you
choose to and then they start grabbing
at your gun and you start shooting in
defense
are you really defending yourself or did
you put yourself in a situation where
you're the aggressor you're defending
yourself even though you're defending
yourself
so uh there's a lot of questions
especially as the analogy pertains to to
kenosha
do you live or work in this area where
there's a mob of people
so that's relevant yeah it is if you're
if you're supposed to be there or you're
defending your community
more importantly though just because of
a group of unruly unlawful people
doesn't mean you as a citizen have no
right to exist and
bear arms or to be there to be there i
mean
i got a right to keep in bear arms so if
i'm walking down i mean
based on what you're saying ian no one
in chicago should be allowed to have
guns period
it's kind of that argument of if you go
into a bear
a cage with a bunch of hungry bears and
the bears attack you are you going to
blame the bears
for attacking you or are you going to
blame the guy for getting in the bear
cage
different similar with what andy noah's
experience sure yeah but they're
completely different circumstances
if you based on your analogy no one in
chicago is allowed to defend themselves
chicago is ridden with crime violence
gang activity
so uh self-defense is now wrong because
you entered this place
that's different than don't go out late
at night you know
because you'll get mugged you go out
night at chicago you know you run the
risk i mean i i've i talked to people in
chicago who are saying they're scared to
go out at night because of it's just
constant it's getting worse and worse
and worse
so many of them stop doing it many of
them are you know people i know are
leaving
we heard about san francisco 40 of
people polled said they were going to
leave because of
declining quality of life that's
different from do you have the right to
defend yourself
if you have to go let's let's say you
have a big house
and one day you show up and there's a
bunch of bears in it
are you allowed to go in and fight the
bears off yeah because it's your house
there's a difference between
i'm you should you go into the house
probably not unless you can defend
yourself good point so it's like it
might be your house there's a bunch of
bears in it right now
you're gonna need some help to clear out
the bears in a very you know
safe way but if you your family was in
there and
it was like your medicine was in there
let's say you're a diabetic and your own
son's in the fridge and you're going to
die it's like you have to go in there's
a choker
and if the barons attack bears tax you
gotta learn how to fight that bear with
your bare hands punch it in the nose
unless you've got i don't know what kind
of gun takes down a bear to be honest
sonic
i think you need it yeah well that's
like well you need a 50 caliber for sure
do you think a 50 kill well i think it'd
be
that would be your well that would that
would be the very least i think you
would need to have a chance
308 though i'd imagine you know if like
not one but
if you get him in the head maybe right i
would assume so i mean i feel that i
feel better about a 50
even though i was in the army you're the
one that lives in the country now and so
you you're more up to speed i don't know
i've not had to fight a grizzly bear
we have a bunch of deer that come here
but we're are we're cool they're here
they're all right there's our first
thing we got turkeys all over the place
the the turkey shot in the 12 gauge is
pathetic
you know what i mean but like it does
the turkeys in i guess if they're a
nuisance on your property
well the turkeys come by once a month we
don't mind them what a but a bear
i don't know i think people in the chat
are going to know uh what does someone
say 338 winchesters no no
338 wm 308 someone said 308.
i figured you know some i don't think i
don't i don't think 45 would work
no not at 45. yeah 45. like standard for
like 45 acp subsonic it's going to
get of turkeys you guys ever hang out
like
face to face with a turkey before
there's a bunch of them they're over
outside
like have you sat within like six feet
of one and just chilled with one ever
i wouldn't call it that you should i was
in south america and this woman was
gonna
was was housing this turkey to eat it
eventually and he would come up and sit
next to us
and they are terrifying because huge
claws they're massive but then you look
in their eyes and they have this kind
wisdom in their eyes
i see why ben franklin wanted to make it
the national bird
they're like the modern uh velociraptors
or something all right here here's
here's a good one here's a good one
victor g says amazing how blue pill tim
is on conspiracies and then cannot
understand how people can be so blind
about how corrupt the media is
uh actually i think you sir are the one
who is blue pilled
if there is something as such as like
overly red pilled i don't know but
there is an idea that when you take the
red pill you wake up from the matrix
but you cannot claim that you you've
seen a meme
and looked at circumstantial evidence
and it's been enough to prove something
definitively
there is a meme that's gone around for a
long time about the about the clintons
and it lists all of these names i have
gone through
a ton of these names and been like
that's the stupidest attempt at
connecting somebody
it's like this one firm once handled a
bank account for bill clinton and
they're receptionists it's like whoa
whoa whoa
like if you've got a company with 3000
people and someone
could you imagine if it's like you know
you go to a shopping mall
and then one day someone in the shopping
mall turns up dead and they're like but
the clintons were shopping there
whoa so coming back to that one i'll
just say that because um
my firm sued hillary clinton on behalf
of tulsi gabbard i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna hope that you're correct
about that one so i i just think this
this latest story with this journalist
it's like he broke a story about loretta
loretta lynch and bill clinton
then for years was writing a book about
it then went on a book tour about
it and the clintons were like not yet
not yet wait for it
wait for it now what's like
if they if they wanted to stop him from
writing the like if they were mad about
what he was reporting would they stop
the book from coming out
it's it was six years later you can't be
like well six years later it's
people are looking too much for
confirmation bias
and they say i'm blue well someone said
i'm blue belong conspiracies bro i'm
doing the investigations and not finding
the evidence
i'm not gonna sit here and pretend
evidence exists when it doesn't there's
certainly things you can bring up that
are creepy
like the painting of bill clinton in a
dress on epstein island
or bill clinton flying on the epstein
plane 27 times or whatever
bro that's creepy stuff that we know
happened
luke luke rodkowski getting on the boat
and jumping onto fc9 island like a
lunatic
getting freaky at fc9
yep yep all right let's see we got
doug andrew says greetings tim and gang
i'm making it a point to watch your
videos on rumble instead of youtube
don't fret though i'm still leaving
likes on youtube all right well that
that's cool
um you know look we have to leverage
these platforms where the culture war is
happening we can't just abandon them
because uh that's where the culture war
is happening so it's it is a challenge
right twitter however i i have complete
disdain for and i tweet nonsense
like i don't i don't maybe i'm still
maybe that's worse
because i'm giving twitter this the best
content you know what i mean
like if i was going to tweet things like
breaking news you know donald trump did
this
okay i guess that's like you know
legitimate serious content instead of
posting pictures of goats and stuff just
like yeah look at this
look at this a deer trying to eat my paw
paw because i i
i can say one can tell that you're sort
of messing with the universe with your
tweets sometimes which is very
fascinating as opposed to cassandra's
just
attack mode following cassandra is the
best it is
all right let's see
know what zork says although i consider
myself an amateur sleuth i believe i can
say with some certainty that the person
that fired on ashley babbitt was on the
other side of the glass
yeah and there's a video of it of the
guy right of the specific i don't know
is there actual video of the guy holding
the gun
releasing the chamber or is it like you
just kind of see where the guy is and
then
no there there there is video of of his
uh
of his hands uh yeah holding uh the the
firearm um he also i i will note um that
he
uh interestingly i think uh removes uh
his one of his hands from the firearm
and seems to take it to his earpiece
that you cannot you cannot see
but that seems to be the natural
conclusion um they're just they're
they're a lot they're
a lot of questions about january 6.
there are a lot of questions about that
about that incident as well
all right zach goo says i work at a
large trucking company we haul
refrigerated goods had a meeting today
about how our trucks aren't being fixed
due to parts on backwater
they also said all oil changes are
suspended due to oil
shortage i've heard some creepy
scuttlebutt
about uh oil and gas oh yeah just
scuttlebutt just
internet rumors people could be freaking
out who knows we'll see so should we
order like
60 pounds of wd-40 or something no
no i i for breakfast i've been having uh
fresh eggs and vegetables from our own
garden it's the greatest feeling when
you're like i eat food of my own
creation you know what i mean the
chickens just like we let them in the
farm to eat the bugs
they got our tomatoes though but we're
kind of happy they did somebody did
i just drink espresso and i have to
start eating more healthy so i'm gonna
come hang out with you but it's it's
just a great feeling to be like we grew
up
oh man we have so many cherry tomatoes
off of yeah did you talk about that in
the show
they do sound it does sound yummy i took
like 20. threw them in a pot with some
olive oil
and then i poured those fresh eggs over
the top and let it egg just
yeah that that those cherry tomatoes
just pop there i
diced a zucchini from the garden and
sauteed it with like uh red wine vinegar
and salt
dude it was next level i did i put a
sausage in there with it and kind of let
the sausage
grease kind of kind of go out really man
it was good
that sounds really good that's the way
to live that's why i'm saying when
people are worried about
there's been food shortages oil
shortages trucker shortages
gas stations are starting to run dry
across the country it's happening they
say it's not a gas shortage it's a
trucker shortage i'm just like
say it all you want okay i got i got
some electric bikes
not too fast i got electric car we'll
see how long that lasts we're getting
the solar panels and stuff
we have these backup batteries and the
power went out here we immediately ran
and plugged in all the backup batteries
and we're still able to do the show even
though storm knocked out the power very
exciting but these batteries come with
solar panels you can lay out in the sun
and plug in
and they they charge off solar it's
fantastic and they're huge if you only
have like
one panel set it would take like
probably three days to fully charge the
box
but we actually have like i think we
have like 24
so you lay them all out on the ground in
the grass plug it in and it charges up
in an hour or two and you can run ac off
of it you can run your washing machine
out it's amazing yeah these things are
fantastic you run multiple batteries
through
all like 24 panels and like eight
batteries can you have them all plugged
in
technically yeah but it's not worth it
to do it that way you just charge the
one up then switch it over and shoot
over and switch it over because you'll
get some
like um diminishing returns well i did
hear your discussion about gold on your
uh
last show um and you know a lot of
people think about that when it comes to
the kind of apocalypse scenario but you
know your discussion of that was very uh
persuasive that that's not really where
you want to go well gold is where you
but but
i don't think the apocalypse is going to
happen yeah gold is excellent if you
think there's going to be an economy
right gold is valuable amongst among
humans but if if we're like talking
mad max right what do you want gold for
i i guess
you know you know what i mean no yeah it
has i mean it's it's useful as a medium
of exchange in a in a
more at least marginally functioning um
society but rather than that it's like
you know food and water and
you know weapons we have been marginally
functioning throughout the last
four six eight thousand years even
though there's been catastrophe and
we still continue gold persistent
function i'm just saying like if we nuke
ourselves
and it's like the last man on earth
you're gonna you're not gonna trade
someone gold they're gonna be like bro i
i don't need i need water do you have
water i'll give you some bread
but even if like the there's a peaceful
divorce and major conflict gold and
silver are are in my opinion
yeah for me good bad it's good it's
certainly good to have in reserve for
sure
yeah i'm i'm definitely interested in
precious metals and cryptocurrency
but you've got to balance it like i'm
not giving financial advice i'm just
saying
for me i think it's important to have a
balance between some different hard
assets stocks and everything
because i remember who you're talking to
they said if the market collapses
then you need to have some liquid assets
so you can move in and out and
yeah but if you put everything in one
basket you know who knows what's going
to happen well you got to be ready to
pounce on assets if the market folds
basically with your well i think what
people realize in 2008 2009 is that you
know
essentially all all paper assets can go
to hell like in one
fell swoop all right we got this one
from dalamar he says john pierce
matthew purse was arrested today for
entering the capitol with a gopro camera
and pressed badges on
friends are unsure of his status right
now he was streaming on twitch and on d
live covering the event he is going to
need a lawyer
so look i am here and i'm trying to help
uh you know everybody uh
everybody they can because a lot of
people need help so uh so so so reach
out um you know each defendant's
obviously
in a different uh scenario in terms of
uh you know the facts of
of each case and um uh again there's
some very interesting things about
january 6th uh it gets more interesting
by the day
yeah the 21.6 talk societ talk show
says tony bob bielinski that's the name
that's the name yeah we were not
actually that close
[Laughter]
pancake astronaut says love the show
trying to create culture
if you could sir shout out my metal band
mind virus
there you go mine just did all right
all right let's see michael
schwabel says there is a video out there
of trump supporters outside in maga hats
asking the police why they're not
stopping them
huh yup seen it that that does exist
he's yelling at the cop like what are
you doing why aren't you doing anything
the cops just like me
that that and that man was fired up
about it yes uh those cops were
no they were ordered to stand down no no
no because if they had gotten into
altercations and fought people it would
have been the worst optical
there's video of the cops letting them
in yeah they were ordered probably to
not get involved
and just be surprised it's obvious that
donald trump obviously donald trump
told all the police you know i'm the
back the blue president they were like
you got it and the cops were like we're
going to make this happen
oh that's another conspiracy theory hold
on hold on it's not a conspiracy theory
trump was like trump was the president
trump supports police
police let people in and help facilitate
the insurrection
let's round up all these capital cops
now the cops that we're defending the
capital okay you guys are free to go
and the cops that refuse to intervene or
open the doors we gotta have
we got to get those cops rounded up and
investigated don't we
i think that uh there's from a factual
standpoint there is no question that
there are capitol hill police that we're
not just letting people in but we're
urging people to come in and i think
that there are
uh very direct and tough
cross-examination questions that need to
be asked of each one of those
individuals
all right let's see what we got um rob's
antenna says tim
in tomorrow war oh spoiler alert for
those that haven't seen tomorrow
because here it comes tim in tomorrow
war
they need two jabs to kill the queen in
the past
when they could just have blown up the
ship in the first place
that's correct yep i did so many
questions
i didn't get that deep in the analysis
all right we're going in we're going in
you guys ready for this
yeah spoiler alerts to the umpteenth
degree for those who have not seen the
tomorrow war
you're not going to want to hear this
but i am going to now tear it to shreds
do it
so the tomorrow war it's about a bunch
of people they're chilling and then all
of a sudden a portal opens and people
from the future come back to the past
saying we are losing a war against
aliens
and we're going to draft people from the
past to fight in the future because
we're desperate
okay i guess sure it's kind of a weird
weird plot but i do appreciate the
uniqueness of it all right let's
let's talk about this so chris pratt
goes in for testing
and they find out that he's going to die
in seven years the war takes place in 30
years
they say you've been drafted they send
him and a bunch of middle-aged people to
the future at some point
someone notes you notice that all the
soldiers that came to the past are very
young
and all the people that go to the future
are very old and they go oh
they're trying to avoid a paradox so
that someone in the past
doesn't interact with himself in the
future and the people come to the past
haven't been born yet
and i'm like oh except in the movie
everyone's dead in the future
everyone is it makes no sense to be like
he dies in seven years and go to work
half a mill
there's only half a million people left
on the planet so why would they draft a
bunch of old people when everyone's
already dead now
who dies first in the movie turns out
chris pratt okay
i'm telling you spoilers chris pratt's
daughter
is his little girl and then he gets
drafted into the future and sure enough
the colonel in command it's his daughter
weird she's pretty badass he says
colonel and she goes well when you know
when people start you know getting
knocked off you wear a lot of names or
whatever basically implying that
you become colonel when everyone else is
killed in the war which is to
imply most of the soldiers are dead
why would they draft a bunch of
middle-aged fat people like this fat guy
to go and fight in a war unless all of
their frontline infantry actually died
already
in which case people from the past who
are actually in the military
would be the ones to be drafted of
course because they'd be like you're
already dead in the future
now we're going to take you and bring
you into the fight in the future
it's it's ridiculous also what if they
pulled someone's dad
into the future and got him killed in
war before he had the kid that was the
soldier from the future
it makes no sense yeah it makes no sense
i i i assure you i could make a better
movie
i could write a better story i'm not
sure if it's because
it's getting late or not but you're just
it's now like above
your level your mind's moving faster
than mine is on this oh dude i i i
already rewrote the whole movie after
watching it yeah i do there's a lot of
movies i'm like okay i'm gonna rewrite
the plot
he was he was a military vet it should
have been shortly after they should have
been only drafting military
there's a whole lot that should have
changed in that moment but you will keep
chris brett
oh definitely he's so good and i thought
and i thought the daughter uh
character she's good too yeah yeah chris
is the only reason to watch that movie
honestly oh she wasn't
i just remember who at where service she
was in live another day
uh 24 uh the jack jack bauer uh oh
interesting
she played the cia agent in uh london um
yes that's right that's where i
recognize her from zack robinson says is
this enough to say i'm sorry
never changed him i can't believe you
read that last night when is the live
chat coming with your live website
streams
that would be fire free culture war
discourse is the best discourse
you could even air at 11 and react to
chat we have a lot of plans but it's
just
let uh i'll break it down you know
there's a lot of people need to
understand uh there's no amount of money
that can get you what you want if it
doesn't exist right
i was hanging out with this dude this
youtube guy and we were in dc
and uh this was actually on uh um
january 20th there's trump's
inauguration
this guy comes down and uh we were
talking and i said so what did you
fly in first class you know to get to
get down here and he laughs and goes
first class i'm way beyond that and i
laughed and i was like oh a private
plane and he goes
dude i took the train and i started
laughing it's like
how do you think you get from new york
to dc do you like why would you spend
five hours like going to get it like
just hop on the train it's much more
relaxing to take
you walk in you hop on the train it's
right there boom you're in dc you're on
the ground and i was like
oh there's no amount of money like if
if you want to get a private plane it
still takes time to go to the airport
charter the plane
get the permissions get on the runway
you're waiting in line
trains faster people don't realize this
so here's what's happening with the
website dev
i can go to the developers and say i
will give you all the money in the world
and they say
there's still only so much work a person
can do in development
you can't have 10 people designing one
thing because then you've got a bunch of
code conflicting with each other and no
one knows what someone else is building
so it actually has diminishing returns
so there's like actually a happy medium
of how many people you can have
developing something
so it takes a long time so we want to
have website streams we want to have
uh so you can listen to the bonus
podcasts we're going to be doing audio
only versions with all the members
podcasts
for people who want lower bandwidth and
want to listen in areas without high
speed and stuff like that
i think rumble already offers a low
bandwidth version as well but we want to
do an audio only
it's going to take a bunch of dev so
websites first
then the mobile app but we're going to
have a ton of crazy content
we're going to have like we already have
technically three shows you have
tim pool show which is me monologuing
team guest irl which is the
conversations we have cast castle which
is the the vlog
the next one we're doing is the
unexplained and the paranormal and all
that stuff it's going to be epic and
we're going to have
that should be starting up in the next
month or so and then we're going to be
doing
tech gaming all sorts of stuff we're
probably going to do
like true crime obviously but we're
going to have a bunch of different shows
i'm so excited to attack tech show oh
yeah but we need weird technology
so so the interesting thing is i think
there's an overlap with you ian in like
the unexplained show
but there's got to be like the the wild
world of science with ian
just got to go crazy so so where so
where do you guys stand in like the you
know the ufo
uh uh revelations with the these
pentagons
i think they're really using it as an
opportunity to uh
raise money for the military right now
as like a kind of a scare tactic but
also i've been studying these things
called talking plasma balls that the
military's been working on
where they'll coordinate lasers uh three
or more into the atmosphere to
to trisect them and create a ball of
plasma which is showing up on radar
and then they can move the ball around
and they're like how does this how can a
ship even move like that but it's
tracking on radar
yeah it's like actual craft i think it's
tesla tech that they've recovered and
i've been working on
lightweight drones since the 30s or 40s
you ever ever point a laser pointer at a
wall when a cat was in the room
and the laser pointer's moving like in
ridiculous ways because you can just
like move the light and the cat's just
like freaking out like
how is it doing this that's what we're
doing right now
we're like look at these ships and it's
probably a guy with the flashlight he's
like
no for like you make that point with the
plasma ball talking plasma walls but but
even even if it's like
plasma whatever it is it could literally
just be that they're in a plane
and it's a high-powered visible laser
moving
and they're like and then it disappears
and they're like whoa it's like you're
looking at a light dude
right it's how is it moving so fast and
turning on a diamond going through
clouds
and it punched a hole in the clouds yeah
high-powered laser how about the craft
i'm really interested in like what are
the materials that they make bob lazar
worked at area 51 he saw like according
to him like i don't know nine different
shapes of craft that apparently can move
and i have friends that have worked
jeremy risk the alien scientist working
on anti-gravity that's a real technology
like if you create enough horizontal
momentum you can kind of negate
vertical momentum and then move things
up so this idea of spinning things super
fast can create
like the ability to lift and i don't
know i don't know
i don't know if air has anything to do
with it all right well let's read a
little bit more because i got i got to
read this one
michael uh hillers says 458 socom kills
pretty much
everything depending on range and load
uh if anyone's ever seen a 458 socom oh
yeah they're
massive but uh yeah yeah i guess i guess
so
um i i don't know would it would it
would a sabo slug in a 12 gauge work on
a grizzly
oh i say if we can talk about tanks i
can tell you a sabo round would take out
a grizzly well
i can't show it on camera but uh we'll
just you know what is this what is a
sabo exactly
a sable round uh i save a round is the
well
that's one we're not going to play i'll
look at earlier but the same around is
the primary
uh i'm like showing you right i can't
switch the camera now
it's a primary tank killing round that
another tank uses uh
it's an armored piercing fins table as
discarding saber round with tracer which
essentially means sabo is the french
word for shu
so essentially it's a it's a depleted
uranium uh dart
it's almost like a long talking about
that yeah i'm just talking about i'm
talking a lot from the shotgun i'm
talking about the big shape
yeah so that that would definitely take
afterwards
so it's it's it's okay when you shoot it
it breaks it breaks out and the slug
comes out
do they always have tracers in them or
is that just the military versions well
this is
this is a shotgun slug so there's no
tracer but it's a polymer tip
and it's going to put a 10 inch hole in
something i imagine it would harm a
grizzly bear
a great deal yeah at least i'd the tank
ground would definitely
kill the grizzlies yeah yeah a lot of
people were saying yeah someone says
12-gauge slug some people are saying
308.
people are saying show it this is
youtube we can't we can only talk about
it
but to my right there's some fancy stuff
oh man if only you could see
actually there was a photo people post
photos when they go on the show and you
can see them on instagram
uh luke got me a flintlock pistol
beautiful yeah it's not it's not an ffl
item or uh an ffl item i think
it's stunning it's just it's gonna be on
display somewhere yeah it's it's not not
a regulated weapon i think screen
from like the colonial days i mean or
the pirates yeah or something oh yeah i
don't know how old it is or it's a
replica
yeah i think all right let's see we got
here
the reaper nation says hey tim would you
ever consider having donut operator on
the show
yes we would standing invite absolutely
yeah
yeah he seems great actually yeah kevin
uh
robillard just posted a bunch of
gorillas oh oh yes and we have a new
shirt
this one's mostly for the skate park
dwelling dennis skatepark denizens
but uh if you go to timcast.com and
click store
we have stickers and shirts that it's
the gadsden snake wearing a beanie on a
skateboard and says don't snake me bro
so it's a play on obviously don't try to
me and also don't tase me bro
don't snake me so in snake is a verb in
in skateboarding or whatever skate
parker culture
everybody kind of waits their turn so
there will be like a rail and one at a
time people will take their turn and you
kind of just you know i'm gonna
sit back it's very anarchic it's very
anarchist you know you're letting
people sort of do their thing but
eventually someone just
barges in and snakes you it's when
you're about to go and they just cut you
off and go and you're like bro don't
snake me dude
so we made shirts and it's a little that
is the one piece of swag i must have at
some point someday
i want to get i'm going to get a bunch
of the stickers yeah but a lot
i posted in a bunch of skateboarders are
hitting me up on instagram and they're
like yes i want the shirt
like you're wearing in the skatepark
don't snake me bro i love it
yeah because they do it man they do it
they don't tase me bro videos just
one of them don't tase me bro one of a
kind
those are the days huh all right let's
see we got here
trick god says tomorrow war you forget
that pratt's generation would be useless
to the president trying to prepare for a
future war
recall that the present still needs to
fight
i saw the best meme ever it's chris
pratt from the tomorrow war
holding his gun which which is a short
barreled rifle with magnification on it
and they're going through like why
someone would be using this weapon
and then it's like it's like someone
from the i can't break it down for you
perfectly but it's like someone from the
future comes to the past and goes to a
gun store
and they're like we need weapons to
fight a war and they're like okay so
i'd imagine you're gonna want you know
like an ar-15 you know uh
standard no no i want a short barrelled
rifle okay so it's going to be what
a short range nope he's like all right
then he's like okay so you're gonna want
like a red dot nope magnification
and they're like huh okay well all right
so these things must be uh
small and up close nope they're massive
oh my gosh
and and they move around so fast that
you'd never actually be able to see them
in those circular like magnification
things because you got to line it up
yeah i didn't i wasn't playing a club
but you don't really bother me
about that movie is the infinite bullets
they had they did
they they did not seem to have to reload
very often
see this is why i really like stargate
sg-1 they use p90s
and they're often in a lot of close
quarter situations
and they often are reloading and they
they actually explain p90s
and the 50 round uh what what is what
yeah the the
magazine i i think i think tomorrow
where producers are not gonna be your
biggest fans after tonight but
i i or you might be or maybe maybe maybe
bring a massive attention consulting
yeah
i i think it really just is it's like in
um the dark knight
what did what what what did uh harvey
dent say he is the batman
yeah yeah that's filling in pittsburgh
so when he's talking to the guy
in court and then the guy's like i'm the
i'm the real mastermind
you know whatever the guy's name is a
fall guy then
harvey dent walks up to him and he pulls
out the gun it clicks and then harvey
grabs the gun
disassembles it and then he says like
chinese made 28 caliber
if you want to assassinate a you a poli
you know a usda i suggest you buy
american
and then i think he's at 28 caliber or
something
and i i saw that and you know but before
i knew anything about guns it never
meant anything to me then i rewatched it
i heard him say that and i was like
20 28 is that what he said huh i looked
it up and all i found were forms of
people saying like what what
what is this like why would we why would
they do that and some people speculated
that producers did it on purpose
like purposefully five five five phone
number no like they knew
gun people would make a thing of it
don't you also think with
some of the movies that are on uh let's
say the streaming platforms like netflix
and amazon that sometimes they're trying
to get the content out like so fast yeah
they don't put the same kind of like
time into things that they used to do
i think that's what happened with the
tomorrow or that was a conclusion i
reached because i watched it too and i
reached a lot of the same conclusions
tim did and i was watching it i was like
i bet tim is over analyzing every single
bit of
stupid movie but at least chris pratt is
in it that's why i watched it
that is true and correct oh i saw this
move some roman
show about the romans and they were like
handling they were getting charged by
the barbarians and they're like testudo
and they all went into their
their arrow protection testudo turtle
form where they're like
but it's not how you handle a charge at
all you'd get wiped out if you're in
test studio formation so they
then the charge came and they were like
falling on top of their just so and all
the comments like what
who what historian is on staff with this
movie crew that told them
so we we've got we've got a pretty tough
question for you before before we sign
off
i'm surprised there wasn't one yet but
oh no there's a bunch of them but i'm
just you're being very difficult
thank you yeah yeah but this one of
course pertaining to kyle rittenhouse
and uh
a lot of people want to know they say
that you've been accused of taking money
from kyle rittenhouse and they'd like to
know if you have a response
uh so so that's completely untrue um you
know and i'm just gonna leave it at that
because
you know there could be pending
litigation about that but that's
completely a thousand percent uh untrue
and never do such a thing
and i wish nothing but the best for kyle
and he's completely innocent needs to be
acquitted i do want to say one thing to
a lot of people too that you need to
understand and i'll throw a reference to
carl benjamin
and akilah hughes's lawsuit sargon of
sargeras you may know him um
he got sued and he kept his mouth shut
about what was going on and let the
courts handle it ultimately he won
i'm not saying anything about this or
whatever that case may be
but i think there's something to be said
for people who
say i'm gonna keep it you know quiet
we're gonna let the courts figure things
out
and for people who go on social media
and start saying this is what happens
what happens what happened
not to say anybody's right or wrong but
i think it's important that especially
in things like this
look i'll just put it this way i've got
my fair share of litigation and i don't
i never talk about it
and people try to drag me into it you
can't you don't bring it up it is a fool
it is a foolish move to get into that
stuff publicly
don't do it but uh a lot of people were
of course asking it so
we're gonna save that one for for last
before we sign off
um we don't we don't shy away from from
the hard questions i read people
smack talking me i try to as well
because we want to keep it real i guess
so uh yeah everybody who watched and
hanging out these friday nights we
really do appreciate it
make sure you smash that like button
subscribe to this show and become a
member at timcast.com because
boy are we expanding the new website is
so cool i wish i could just
put it up now because of how amazing it
looks but we're getting there we're
getting there and i think we're gonna
have like
five or six i think we'd have six
writers six reporters to start
it's gonna be fantastic so you can
follow this show on facebook and
instagram
at tim cast irl we're on tick tock tim
cast
underscore irl and you can follow me
personally
at timcast basically everywhere else and
uh we we
will have the cast castle vlog up
tomorrow at 9am so you this i i think
this is the best episode ever
this is the best vlog we've ever done
it's the fourth of july special
we're on boats there's animation in it
i was i'm super excited for this uh kent
who does the all the editing work and
everything just hit this one out of the
park
so definitely make sure you go to
youtube.comcastcastle subscribe to that
and tomorrow morning you can watch our
silly fourth of july adventure we had a
blast we made ice cream and cheesecake
and we have throwing axes and it's just
all sorts of shenanigans
and we make fun of sheamus coughlin of
freedom tunes ah
sheamus we love you uh did you want to
shout anything out john
uh no look it was awesome to be here of
course uh please go to nclu.com uh we
need
support to help people whose
constitutional rights are being violated
we really really do
um so thank you for having me uh it's
great fun if people want to get in touch
with you
to work with you what's the best way for
them to get in touch with you uh sure so
on
twitter um i am calikidjmp
um if they're interested uh in
supporting the nclu they can go to
ncou.com
and they can reach out to the email
address uh info nclu.com
and we'll receive those it's really good
talking to you man thanks for coming
thank you so much
you guys can follow me in crossland.net
and hit me up at ian crossland on social
media looking forward to talking to you
thank you guys all very much for hanging
out on this friday night instead of
going and doing fun crazy stuff i know
it's super hot so stay safe
you guys are more than welcome to follow
me on twitter at sour patch lids as i
attempt to have more followers and sour
patch kids
we definitely need to do a show on
comics video games and culture because
like i got so much to say about tomorrow
we're gonna go with you and right right
and and games and and dnd
we're planning on doing a dnd show for
sure a weekly d
show is gonna be a blast we're we
actually talked about this a while ago
about finding a dungeon master to like
help put together really interesting and
dragons yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah that's my generation but but
there's interesting things we can do
with it in terms of politics like
having someone drop a scenario
pertaining to american political
conflict but in the c
like a d kind of game tomorrow we're
going to go see black widow
came out i think uh today when he was a
midnight showing and there's so much i'm
going to have to say about it we got to
do we got we got we got to put together
a new podcast for culture and stuff too
so we got we had a lot coming
it's all thanks to all of you who are
members at timcast.com the site is
expanding rapidly
and everyone who signs up when that
money comes in i just think about how
many more people are going to hire to do
awesome stuff
and so thank you very much thanks for
hanging out we'll see you all next time
bye guys
you